this is jocko podcast number 313 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
he looks like any other ordinary young
afghan
a dusting of a dark beard sun leathered
face
a small child clinging to his side
only nasa fula
is a proud member of afghan's isis
affiliate known
as isis k or informally as dash
he has long been wanted by everyone from
u.s troops and the now defunct afghan
security forces
and the taliban formerly known as the
islamic emirate of afghanistan
nosfula
says he joined the terrorist group
around five years ago out of frustration
that the taliban was dishonest about the
status
of its shadowy leader
we kept asking the taliban to show us
video of mullah omar but we couldn't get
any he claims
that is why the dash here was created
they seemed truthful
and said they were going to implement
sharia law so that is why i joined them
taliban founder omar died in 2013 yet it
was kept secret for more than two years
most isis-k recruits are believed to
have defected from taliban branches in
afghanistan and neighboring pakistan
seeking an even more extreme
interpretation of islam with more
international rather than domestic
centered goals of caliphate
control then the terrorist outfit has
attracted a wealth of foreign recruits
bent on attacking nato
afghan forces
and the insurgency turned taliban
government
the emirate came to power on august 15th
isis k has waged a deadly spat of
suicide attacks and targeted bombings
across multiple provinces and claimed
dozens of lives
while some assaults have targeted the
taliban the vast majority have been
inflicted upon innocent civilians
particularly the minority shiite
population
nazifullah
says he is unclear how many isis k
members are hidden inside afghanistan
he spent the last year locked away in
the country's notorious bagram prison
having been arrested by the previous
afghan government for his isis
membership
however when the taliban swept to power
in august
he says he was released even though the
new regime was aware of his checkered
past
nazifula went straight back to the
black-clad terror clan
but says he has since broken his leg
seemingly from an accidental discharge
from his own rifle
yet he remains ready to take up arms
again with a very specific goal in mind
our first target is to destroy pakistan
because the main reason for everything
in afghanistan
is pakistan he vows
when the taliban were here they were
saying that we control 80 of the country
but they were not implementing islamic
rulings that's why we stood up in when
we started isis k over in this area
continues
then in the parcel under their dominance
the outfit immediately began quote
implementing islamic rulings
like cutting hands and everything
so that's when the taliban got funding
from pakistan and started fighting us
back he claims with a big smile
and at that time
baghdadi announced the caliphate in our
area and we were on top
that's why we are against the taliban
although nazifullah asserts that his
outlawed group is quote weak now and
attempts to downplay their lethality
their hardline goals remain firmly in
place
we want to implement sharia law
we want to implement the way our prophet
was living the way he was clothed
the dressing hijab was there
currently we don't have much to fight
but if you give me anything
i am going to fight pakistan now
yet hauntingly nazifullah also makes it
clear that isis k has far more global
reaching ambitions
whoever goes against islam and against
the quran he adds darkly
we are against them
and that is an article
from knews.com
the article is written by holly mckay
holly is a journalist she's an author
she's a war reporter and she is an
extremely courageous human being
she's been on this podcast before
number 271
where
she talked about her experiences
in the war against isis in iraq and
syria which she chronicled in her
incredible book
which is called only cry for the living
and she's back with us again tonight to
share with us her experiences from
afghanistan
because she was there she was there
during the american departure
the collapse of the government
and the rise to power and control of the
taliban
so holly
welcome back and i do mean that
sincerely i was watching through social
media when you were in afghanistan
and i was terribly worried about you
and we'll discuss why i'm sure we'll get
to some of that it was definitely
sketchy to say the least but for now i
am truly glad that you are here
and you went there for a reason
to learn
to capture
what was happening and you've done that
so let's talk about
let's talk about what you've been
through first of all welcome back thank
you thank you for having me it's strange
adjusting so it's been a few days and
i'm still getting used to no you know
highway without
bombed and potholes and like oh this is
a nice road hang on a minute
um just to set the stage a little bit to
to bring you into afghanistan when you
went back when you went to afghanistan
this time
just to get
where what you stepped into
july 2nd
germany and italy withdraw from
afghanistan that is the same time that
america
quietly
and strangely left bagram air base
july 8th
biden announces
that the war is going to be over and
we're going to be out by august 31st
july 12th
general miller who is the commander uh
commander of us and nato forces in
afghanistan he steps down
and by the way this is right as
taliban is seizing district after
district by mid july they seized you
know 140 or 150 districts
inside of afghanistan
july
21st
[Music]
general milly reports that half the
districts
in afghanistan are under taliban control
so
july 22nd the u.s house of
representatives they they pass a bill
for visas for our interpreters and and
other allies that were there
and the reason i bring that up is
because that turned into a big deal as
everything shut down
and so that's what we're going into it's
very obvious i forget the quote from
general milly but it was something along
the lines of
everyone was
surprised at how fast it was collapsing
but it was collapsing quick so august
7th is when you arrive in kabul
what was your purpose and going there
did you did you know how fast it was
falling down did you like hey this isn't
going to make it i'm going to go in
there anyways
what was that what was the thought
process there so i made the decision i
think it was around may june that i was
going to go back in august with my
photographer jake who's australian he's
also spent a lot of time he lived in
afghanistan and spent a lot of time in
in other places so
we thought we would go back and document
what i thought was going to be the the
last month of the americans being there
and then
the afghan government trying to stand on
its own two feet
so between making that decision
and what happened it just you couldn't
you could i just i did not realize it
was going to happen that quickly
and so when i arrived even that first
week
i was going to meetings at nds which is
the afghan intelligence i was going to
meet with all these different people and
everybody was just so convinced that it
wasn't going to fall immediately at
least not within say that month
and
it's so the speed of it and i've had to
do so much reflection on this and
looking back and going where did you
miscalculate how did this sort of happen
so quickly
and it really just goes to show
i think nobody really had any idea at
the end of the day i think
there were there were sort of
intelligence failures on many different
levels from many different from parts of
it
i've talked about some of this um
if i'm a
company commander
and i'm in charge of training afghan
forces
i want to do a good job
and
when i report to my battalion commander
and i you know the first i'm working
with these guys for a month and you know
he says how are those guys and i say
well they got some work to do
they're not that great they're deficient
here they're deficient there they're not
good at this
and my battalion goes commander says
okay well you know get them squared away
the next month what do i say you know
i'm gonna tend to say yeah well we're
making some improvements
we're doing a little bit better we've
got them issued better gear we we got
the supply issues taken care of that we
were worried about we did a
live fire training operation and
and so you end up
just by virtue of having a positive
attitude which americans certainly have
we end up
painting a better picture than what is
actually happening i i saw this i i try
to think if i did this i believe i did i
believe that i did in training iraqi
forces
would sometimes say
you know
um i would put some lipstick on
on on the situation a little bit
again trying to have a positive attitude
trying to look at the brightest side of
what was happening in and there was
times
in in iraq where
the iraqis would take over a position
and the
insurgents would immediately attack it
and crush them and so we got put in
check a few times i would almost say
luckily
because that what that caused us to do
was to be very honest about the
capabilities of the people we were
working with so there is actual times
where the iraqis would take over let's
say a checkpoint
we'd say yup they're good to go and this
is when i say we i mean coalition forces
in general you know the americans that
are there said yes we've been working
with these iraqis they can handle this
checkpoint we'd step away from the
checkpoint
and this happened almost immediately
upon my arrival
this checkpoint got taken over by the
iraqis and the insurgents attacked it a
day later two days later
they killed the
american advisor that was there actually
two american advisors that were there
overran it was total disaster and that
happened when i first showed up
so it really put us in check in terms of
okay what do we need to be very cautious
about what we report up the chain of
command and when they're actually ready
but at the same time
you know i my guess is and even when we
left iraq i was very worried i was very
worried when america left iraq when
coalition forces left iraq i thought to
myself
they can't they're not ready yet
and there's a
there's a similar obvious similar theme
here
so
almost every i never fought in iraq in
afghanistan but
everyone that i know that worked on the
ground with the afghan forces
were all not surprised
hey they weren't ready yet they just
weren't ready yet
and it's a huge it's
it's um
it's almost like
when you have these these elements
the us support is really like the long
pole in the tent and all the other
tent poles and the canvas that goes over
the tent is and the stakes that go on
the ground all those things are really
really important and you can build those
up and you can make them really good and
you can they can provide you shelter
from the rain and shelter from the wind
but if you pull out that one long pole
in the middle
it has a huge negative impact and and
that's sort of
again in hindsight as i look at it
that's what that's one of the things i
think happened yeah i think there were
just multiple things i think even right
down to the number of ghost soldiers so
on paper there might be 300 000 afghan
soldiers when there's in reality there's
a a quarter of that because people would
take commanders were taking money of
people that never existed or they were
dead or there was no accountability um
you know i can i can go into corruption
for days in in how that really destroyed
afghanistan and
so to drill into that corruption that
you just thought let me let me see if i
got this little piece of it right i'm a
commander i'm a i'm an afghan commander
if i say i have 500 soldiers i get x
amount of money yep
so guess how many i have 700. and and
two of you guys die you're not going to
report that because you still want to
keep getting their money to the point
where they would take the bank cards of
the dead soldiers and go to the bank and
get them their paychecks every week or
every month like it's the level and we
can get into this but
in my i've never seen a more corrupt
place on every possible level
and yet
you know we and when i say we i say
united states we turned a blind eye to
that for for really 20 years instead of
going to the root and fixing it we let
it fester and create this entire
industry of corruption which is what the
taliban was not only able to capitalize
on but they came in saying
we're not going to be corrupt and people
that don't even like the talibans were
so fed up with that corruption that they
were going to support that even if they
didn't support the ideology
so you get there on the 7th the eighth
and ninth you're meeting with intel
people
it's still not clear that this thing is
going to fall apart or are you or is it
i think there was this idea of well
kabul was never going to fall and
certain pockets like kabul pangaea you
know even mazar which is where i ended
up these were very very staunch
resistance places and there was sort of
this idea that how can they possibly
fall
and
so i i met with and i had actually
stayed with him in 2018 and uncarl was
general dustin so general dostum was the
the warlord i guess who the u.s troops
first went in with from the north during
um after the 911 and that's where mike
spann was killed and sort of the first
people there so i'd met him several
years ago um in turkey and did a profile
with him and so he invited me to go back
to missouri because he was leading some
resistance forces there that were
working with the afghan commandos
and
yeah it was just sort of this idea and i
i guess looking back it was you know
selling a story that didn't exist but
we decided okay well let's go and cover
what's happening in mazar
even though the northern provinces
surrounding it were all sort of falling
there was this sense that mazar was
going to hold so we went to mazzar it
was uh very early on a thursday morning
how did you get up there we flew okay
yeah come here
and
so it's about a 50 minute flight from
carmel to mazzar
and so
we can say did you say a 50-minute
flight yeah 50-minute flight and was
this who who's who's flying the
helicopters is this just charging this
is a commercial airliner
yeah i flew a commercial airline two
weeks ago so they still exist
i was glad to land that one because
there was no landing lights
um but but they're still at commercial
airlines so we flew to mazzar because at
this point you couldn't travel on roads
anywhere which isn't something else
that's changed significantly now but but
then you couldn't you that you could the
taliban had really cut off every
strategic road and
you couldn't go much beyond sort of
kabul maybe kabul to pangaea but that
was a sort of the most road travel you
could do so we flew to
mazzar
that was really early in the thursday
morning
and you get there and it was just this
incredibly vibrant place and i just
remember it was the
how
how is there
how are all these provinces around this
place falling to the taliban when the
markets would just chalk a block and
everybody is just going about their
daily business
i was flabbergasted and i thought
isn't like what is happening and you'd
go and sort of talk to people and they'd
be oh i'm a little bit worried but it's
okay i think it'll be okay we'll just
flee to kabul
um so that was the thursday and
everything yeah very normal yeah so your
feeling was okay well obviously this is
gonna be okay yeah and and i you know
had a couple of friends who were very
worried about me being in mazzar and i i
was sort of like
seems fine to me
um but but what did really struck me as
as weird was that there was no police
there was no military presence on the
street at all
i didn't see a single
like afghan
forces come through and i i thought that
was strange i thought where is where is
this like this city this is in the
middle of a a firestorm here and there
is
zero security forces right now
so that struck me as strange but
everybody was going about life
and then the next day friday which is
the weekend day in afghanistan but still
things were out and i was going out
interviewing people
just asking them how they felt people in
the markets and people were starting to
feel really worried they said well
you know we think it's gonna fall but we
just don't know when it's going to
happen
and
as the day progressed you felt it get
a little bit
people were becoming more tense and we'd
go to this there's a beautiful big blue
mosque a big shrine there that's that's
quite famous and there were just a lot
of people that had fled from other
villages and other provinces and they
were all sort of hanging out outside
this mosque and
and by the evening things were still
happening but
i
you know i said to jake my photographer
okay we need to book this return flight
back to kabul
and so i get online and then like the
earliest flight we can get is monday
night
and i was like i think it's you know i
called a few people i was like is it
gonna hold
um and they were like yeah you know you
should be fine but but get out in the
next flight you can get
back to
to kabul and so i booked the flight so
you're online booking a flight which
means you're online watching news and
seeing updates from other things yeah
yeah
and it's still you got the impression
because i'm i don't remember exactly i
knew that you were in mazar
through social media because you're
you're like posting about this stuff
um
but i also remember seeing you know sort
of the battle map of what's happening
and seeing the various provident
provinces collapse around
and i just remember thinking get please
get out of there
[Music]
so yeah and i remember thinking that too
and i thought that this isn't this this
doesn't feel right but that night we
went out with the commandos the afghan
commandos too and they were taking a lot
of hits and a lot of you know a lot of
fighting but
they were such extraordinary and again
you know this this perhaps walked my
thinking a little bit too but you had
these men who were just like we will
never give this up they will never get
mazar we will you know and and defend it
and hold it and just really great young
men
and
we stayed out with them until about two
o'clock that morning and there was this
sort of strange sense with with one of
them his name was safi and and he kept
you could tell how much he missed the
west he wanted us to stay and drink beer
with him and and listen to music and he
just he didn't want us to leave he just
he wanted he wanted this sense of this
connection to to the west that i think
that you know being trained by the
americans and just have this sort of
deep love
um so two o'clock came we got the guys
to take us back to our hotel and we're
supposed to go out with them again at
around seven or eight that morning
so we wake up on the saturday and i'm
waiting for a call from him he's not
there he's not answering his phone
and i thought you know god i hope he's
okay this is strange i don't know what
to do but i will just wait for him to
contact me again
um and then we thought well let's go out
and do some stories and we tried to
contact some fixers or interpreters that
we had known lived there everyone had
fled to kabul we could not find anybody
eventually by mid-morning we found
somebody who knew somebody who said that
he could he could come and be an
interpreter if we did some interviews
and so
we went out and it was just suddenly
this ghost town from this it had gone
from
extremely vibrant you know place to this
complete ghost town you just saw people
lining up outside banks just trying to
get their money out
um and we're walking and
people are just fleeing from the outside
villages into mazar on those little
rickshaws and you know with all their
stuff and and we met with this
interpreter and we get into a a cab and
we're driving out toward there was three
front lines
and the interpreter who i didn't really
know too well um is on the phone as
we're driving and it's about midday and
he suddenly he looks at me and he turns
around he's got this big smile on his
face
and he says oh they just broke through
the first of the three lines
and it's surrounded and
we looked at each other and and the cab
driver was like i'm really scared
because we're sort of driving toward it
and i said okay that's fine we'll we'll
turn around and go back it's no big deal
um
so we went back and i went you had this
detail that you just gave yeah
he was smiling yeah he was and i still
can't figure out why he was smiling if
he just didn't care or if he was a
taliban or if he
just was trying to appease me
he thought hey i'm getting to get you
some stories they just broke through
here yeah
turns around and it's just this they
just broke through the first
and
and i'm like okay
um
so i get back to the hotel and i'm
trying to make some phone calls because
like there's no there's no flight out
that i can get earlier than that monday
and
there's no way it can you know it's a
ten hour drive but there's no way i
could even attempt to do that drive
because it's all taliban controlled
and so i'm making some calls to you know
again to my intel contacts in kabul and
even then they're saying no no it should
hold it'll hold don't worry
um and i was starting to get pretty
worried and i was distracting myself you
know doing some work and things and then
and then we normally go to this there
was a kebab cafe that we'd always go to
each night and it was a really lively
place it was underground they would play
these terrible soap operas but there was
always like a lot of people there
playing music
and so jake and i said okay well let's
go to this kebab cafe and we step out
it's just pitch black and not a single
person around
and i'm still figuring out we walk to
this kebab cafe
and it's open we're like oh it's open
and we go downstairs and the tv is off
and there's just these the two guys that
work there that are just sitting there
and we order food and we're sitting
there and then we just look at each
other and we're like something is really
really wrong
we need to go
and so we get up and we start hurrying
back toward the hotel this was early
evening around seven
and then you just see those motorcycles
coming in and that's the taliban
and so we sort of hurry back just in
time to get to hotel and go to the roof
and i'm just looking out and the taliban
is just circling there's just hundreds
of them and they're shooting in the air
and they're playing their nasheed which
is their religious music and and
celebrating that they just took a city
without
firing a shot basically um but what also
struck me during the day and that was
the other bizarre thing i thought
here is a city that's falling and
there was no air power there was not a
sound in the air and i remember that
something and i did a little video about
i was like where is the air power
didn't we train didn't we put
just tens hundreds of millions of
dollars into this afghan air force where
the hell is it because i don't hear it
and air power is a great example of the
long pole in the tent right
the if you have air power when the
taliban's coming in on their motorcycles
and in their trucks it it they can't you
literally can't do it and that's the
long pole in the tent
that falls apart when that happens
you know it's um
as you were talking about like the
talking to one of the afghan soldiers
that you knew
and how he you know hey we're gonna stay
here we're gonna fight they'll never
take us
do you remember all that stuff that
happened up in portland when the antifa
took over the part of the yeah part of
the neighborhood or whatever they were
calling it i think it was originally
called chop and then they changed it to
jazz but it was the occupied zone or
something like this but somebody was
asking me about it
and i kind of said
hey there's no one up there
in the chop
that's like ready to die for the cause
that's ready to say you know what we're
going to stay here worry
they're just not there's not up there
there's no i mean america
and i kind of made the comment that hey
even the people that are antifa members
guess what they have cell phones and
they have you know like nice they have
clothing and they have running water and
it's just not that bad of a thing and
they're not right that committed to it
and
it's it's interesting when you think
about what it really takes
for someone to stand up and be willing
to sacrifice themselves for a cause
whatever that cause is and when you look
at the taliban and you you're this
afghan
person that's been fighting for however
many years and you've been fighting for
the americans you've been fighting for
the afghan government for 10 years or
seven years
and then you're like well it looks like
we're completely surrounded
if i fight i'm gonna die or i can just
kind of put down my weapon take off my
uniform and carry on with my life
and i yeah and that was you know i i
think it was sort of the next day
well joe biden came out and said
you know these guys ran away from their
posts and things and and to a degree i
understand where that came from but it
actually it upset me because
they were really sold out by their
leadership and and i'll give you
examples so saffy the guy that i met
that friday when i was finally able to
get back in contact with him after mazar
had fallen and i asked him are you okay
where are you
and he said you know he'd gone out that
day and and they just they were so
outnumbered and his three bodyguards had
been killed and
um you know it was really the commanders
that were trying to hold it and he said
by four o'clock that afternoon somebody
came to him and said oh dust and left
and so did the commando left like all
your commanders left and it's up to you
if you want to stay and die or you can
leave and he just
he they were sold out by everybody
i i did hear stories um from guys that i
knew
that said
that the taliban would like approach a
village yep and just send a messenger in
there and be like hey you know here's
your chance we know you were you know
you we know you're afghan security um
you can put down your guns and be cool
or we're gonna kill everyone and guys
were like uh okay we're surrounded we're
gonna die um i guess we'll just
yeah go back to the way it used to be by
the way that's the other thing it was
they have sort of a lot of them had
memory of what it used to be like and
it's like okay well i guess
we're going back the way it used to be
but it's better to do that be alive than
be dead
and the amount of sacrifices that a lot
of those afghan soldiers made i mean
they don't they won't even release the
number of killed but it's
it's well past 100 000. yeah i mean
there was at least 50 000 killed going
into
this whole thing taking place yeah so
it's not like and again there's plenty
of
americans that fought alongside the
afghans and had met awesome afghan
troops just like in iraq in other words
and
by the time you were in iraq
and the
iraqis were fighting isis they were
taking massive casualties massive
casualties going to take mosul back that
was led by the iraqi forces and they
took massive casualties and they kept
going
compared to in in the battle of ramadi
the iraqi forces were
some of them were very scared and didn't
want to take lead and definitely didn't
want to take casualties we had whole
battalions abandon and leave
so
that idea of
this kind of
this kind of clear-cut american version
of the way things are
is doesn't apply here there's no
clear-cut
way of
hey
oh if you get cat if you're an american
you get captured we know what's going to
happen you're going to get tortured you
get killed it's like hey you're an
afghan security force and you
surrender
you're not sure what's gonna happen but
you know what's gonna happen if you
don't surrender you're gonna die
so
and then you see your leadership
all running away all running away all of
them
and every single one of them ran away
including the president including the
president yeah including the president
who
yeah with that guy that is a is an
insane situation i mean you have that
guy ashraf ghani who
who is like a professor at berkeley a
professor at johns hopkins uh went to
some leadership school at harvard
wrote the book called fixing failed
states which is like an academic
exploration of this stuff theoretical
it's an embarrassment yeah and he bailed
with a bunch of money by the way and and
yeah a bunch of money is now under
investigation but what what i remember
going back in being afghanistan in 2017
and sort of hearing when i'd go to the
the nato compound of the us embassy and
everyone would say all these great
things about ghani and i remember saying
to a few people have you gone out to the
street just to talk to the afghan people
because they have a different idea you
know so i think part of that problem was
the us because nobody was leaving that
base in the diplomacy world they were
getting a vacuum of information that was
pre-approved people to enter they were
all part of this sort of puppetry stream
and they weren't actually out there
talking to the afghans who were terribly
frustrated with the corruption going on
terribly frustrated with the sort of i
guess the the pashtun and the
sectarianism and things and it just
the picture that was was so warped
compared to the reality that i saw even
back then
and that was so 2017 you're out talking
to normal people and they're totally
frustrated with gandhi and yet the
americans are getting this white-washed
version of how and how he's doing an
excellent job yeah
um
when
so it was like august 14th so mazar
falls
kabul falls too so that was so that was
the saturday night so you know suddenly
i'm like in the in this room in this
hotel and and the the locals had all
fled and there were no foreigners in
there except i think there was a guy
from tajikistan who was there for a
couple of days and someone else but
so when jake and i look at each other we
said well what are we what are we gonna
do
um you know we're making some calls and
i'm speaking to some some dod people in
kabul and they said well you know go and
get us measurements go and get us
coordinates go and get us this and that
and we'll see if we can get you out in
the morning the early morning
and
it was a interesting night so you had um
you had you know i was trying to get all
this information and then
the morning and the talibans were out
having a crazy you know taliban party
all night um and so by the morning light
i thought well they'd gone to sleep then
because they celebrated all night and
they'd gone to sleep but then nobody's
calling um they were just sort of
looking at each other going well now is
kind of the chance to get out in this
period where they're not in the street
because they're going to be in the
street in a couple of hours
um but it became very evident that just
it wasn't going to happen and then
then that sunday
we started seeing news reports that the
that the talibans were at the gates of
kabul and then the next thing you know
they're taking the palace and we just
sort of i looked at
i looked at jake when that happened and
i said well
yeah we're pretty much
we've got to figure this out
were you feeling
were you feeling threatened with when
the taliban showed up so the images that
they were portraying of the taliban was
uh
was like a a kinder gentler taliban was
coming in right it was like you said it
was it was like celebratory yeah it
didn't look like a angry mob it looked
like a happy mob that was celebrating
and
that that was sort of the images that we
got initially then it quickly turned
into images of people being people being
killed people being murdered um but what
was your initial impression
my initial impression was it was just
bizarre because they were the it i was
like who are these barbarians in the
street like how is this like and then
they're doing announcements over the
loudspeaker and it was so strange
because you saw this instant
transformation of a of a city and and
they did they did look a little you know
intimidating and there were just so many
of them and that was the thing i thought
where did these people come from because
mazzar was a very strong taliban
resistance place and suddenly it's just
there's hundreds of them and
i don't know where you they come from
and i i sent jake out to buy me a burger
at the market and he just came back he's
like oh my god they're just they're
crazy you know and so we were trying to
i guess figure out what do you mean by
crazy okay just like th they're they're
just everywhere okay and they're just
you know they literally have
sort of the dominance of
every corner possible in the city and
that was their strategy i think in the
very beginning when they took places
they just flooded it with flyers to make
sure that they could hold it
now a normal person would like
concentrate on hiding and getting out of
there but you kind of focused on let's
go interview people so not not quite so
i i mean
at first i went a little quiet i was
like i don't know
and i was trying to pretend to my
parents i wasn't in the city because
straight away my dad's like we just
heard on the newsmazar's fallen are you
there i said
no i'm outside the city
um so i was trying to yeah to try to
appease them a little bit but uh so i
was a little unclear
and
and what sort of had concerned me at
that point was
i know that first night that they came
in and there was a bank underneath the
hotel so they were so the talibans were
desperately trying to get into
the hotel where we were and we knew that
we were the only foreigners in there at
that point and
and these incredible hotel staff had
stayed there for us and they were
terrified because they'd all been former
nds or previously worked in different
capacities with the afghans and i knew
that they were desperately wanting to to
go home to you know safety or flee or
their families but they really stayed
there for us and that was
um just something that i thought was
just extraordinary and it goes back to
that afghan hospitality and and care um
so we were there and and so several days
are going by and the focus was to get
out but it just
it became so and my phone was just
blowing up with so many different people
telling me do this do this do this and i
was just like you all need to leave me
alone at this point please because it's
not helping
um
and i said to you know the us people
that i was speaking to right from the
beginning i think the only way is you go
and talk like i need to go and talk to
them to get their permission to leave
because
there really wasn't another way there
wasn't really a way that i felt that i
could sneak out or you know go under the
radar
and
yeah that was that was what i was
pushing for from the beginning so that
was sort of my focus in in doing that
so it falls on like the 14th 15th and
you spend the next few days trying to
figure out what the best course of
action is and so what'd you finally
figure out so um yeah we i talked to so
many different people and i thought you
know any sort of rescue any whatever is
not going to happen so i talked to a
couple of diplomats and then i talked to
um sort of i guess a middle person who
was a afghan business guy
and so it was very very quick and then
he sort of said well i'll come to the
hotel
um
and you know be ready at this time and
they'd heat some things up with the
uzbek console which was closed but they
were able to kind of get it open so next
thing you know i'm dragging my stuff
down and the two people that come to
meet me is my drivers are the two
taliban elders you know the
cousin of the
his shadow governor turned new governor
so you see these sort of old taliban
guys and and i'm getting into the car
with them and they were like welcome
it was so bizarre joko it was
i was like
what
a hi
um because at that point we really
didn't know well it's just you and jake
getting into this yeah just jake and i
getting into the car with the talibans
and we didn't know at that point you
know how they're going to treat a
foreigner how they were going to treat a
woman how they were going to treat a
journalist
um and so yeah they they drove us
through the city and i so i said do you
mind if i have a talk to you and ask you
some questions and they said sure
and
um
you know telling me about i'm asking
them about their how they viewed islamic
law and sharia law and what they wanted
and they just sort of said well you know
we want people's hands to be topped off
when they steal and
if you murder then you should be your
eye for an eye kind of thing and and
telling me all about their their rulings
and um but at the same time they're like
yeah you you're welcome in afghanistan
you're welcome to stay as long as you
like
and uh we hope you enjoy our country
and it was very bizarre and then we were
dropped off at the uzbek console
and then suddenly these other talibans
came
um and they were there's a group of them
really young ones like in their early
20s
and they were going to be our escort and
the only way sort of because we couldn't
go back to kabul was to go north to the
uzbek border and so you had these bunch
of these young talibans who were just
who wanted to take selfies
and you know continue to send they
continued to send long after that my
photographer you know selfies of
themselves with you know urdu music in
the background and love heart emojis
it's literally the most bizarre thing
you could imagine i was looking at
pictures um on some of your articles you
have pictures of these taliban guys
like with their iphones or whatever yeah
out they're doing selfies yeah it's
freaking for social media yeah and they
and they harass and i know with there's
a couple of other photographers that i
know and they harass poor jake and any
other photographers get arrest for their
photos so if you take a picture of a
telemen's oh i need your whatsapp i need
your whatsapp and then they just harass
and they want pictures of themselves
like it's just it's so new to them these
are people who are in hiding in the
mountains for 20 years and then suddenly
they're like out and free and kind of a
spectacle it's
it's very bizarre
how does
selfies
and instagram match up with sharia law
i'm not sure about that one i guess it's
it's
it's too new for sharia maybe how does
that work they haven't put a ruling on
it yet
um
man that's crazy um so you
were you at any point at what point did
you go i think i'm gonna be okay
did the old taliban make you feel that
way did the young taliban make you feel
that way i think well
i did i did feel like i was going to be
okay even when i was stuck in the hotel
i think the first night i was
a little bit well you you had a normal
sense of fear i guess i certainly i
didn't panic but i i was a little bit
thrown this wasn't in the plan
um at all and but actually it's the
small things that make you feel good i
remember this this young man from the
hotel came up to me and he said and he
put the manager of the hotel on the
phone to me the owner and the owner said
to me
don't worry i've already talked to the
talibans and they promised not to enter
the hotel and i thought that was just
like christmas i was like thank you and
i just even though i didn't know whether
that was true whether they were going to
honour that which they certainly weren't
because they were trying to get in but
it was like just what i needed to hear
at that point to give me that sense of
calm that i needed to to focus on on
what it is i needed to do
um in mazar i saw i saw images and it
was pretty prominent in in the news back
here
sort of as cobble fell
like uh let's say there was like a
women's clothing boutique
and then they choked the next day to be
gone or it'd be now whatever selling
shovels or something like that
did mazar go through that really rapid
transition from like more western
influence just to boom overnight all of
a sudden yeah it was very overnight and
mind you that was that was
self-censorship that wasn't the taliban
going around telling them yeah that was
me going oh you know i'm not going to be
selling these weapons freaking bikinis
anymore we're shutting it down yeah yeah
so
yeah mazar really it was just this
drastic but what i found fascinating was
the the clothing transformation so
you see people you know walking around
in western jeans or whatever it is and
then suddenly everybody's in afghan
dress
and very very traditional um and that
was sort of the bizarre thing and it
took a couple of days before i saw a
woman again on the street and when i did
she was always in a burger
so that was very it was it really felt
like you went from one civilization and
then you just plunged back a couple of
hundred years overnight and even just
there were these messages coming out of
the speakers which i'd never heard
before in mazar either so the same
speakers that they used for the call to
prayer were suddenly delivering messages
you know sort of town hall messages to
people you know telling them that um you
know if anybody steals from them or
anybody does anything and they're to
call this number or come to this place
to report it and so you have this
immediate sense of the taliban's trying
to to govern suddenly
but yeah it was so drastic that that
transformation
so how do you get up to the uzbek border
just driving up there the talibans so
the talibans took us
i know
so the talibans take us to the uzbek
border which is back water is closed but
again that they
you know so a couple of really amazing
diplomats in in tashkent which capital
of uzbekistan had made arrangements with
the uzbek consulate to open the border
which i actually found out i didn't even
need because both of us had australian
passports and we didn't need a visa for
uzbekistan but americans do so
i could have gone anywhere i guess but
they had to open especially for us
because it was closed because the night
before when mazar had fallen or the the
nights before when mazar had fallen
the soldiers flooded that border because
they had nowhere else to go so they
really flooded that border and you drive
along the way and you just see all the
you know the american vehicles and the
humvees and everything just abandoned
and left behind and the weapons still
lying on the road and the the you know
the fatigues and and these were just
afghan soldiers these were just afghan
soldiers and they were going for
uzbekistan yeah because that was the
closest route that they could go to get
out and so i think they let a certain
amount in and then they just shut the
border how hard was it if i was a
corporal or a private in the afghan army
and the taliban's come and how hard is
it for me to be able to like take off my
uniform grab some traditional clothing
and leave and get away with it you
wouldn't be able to get out of the
country i mean they weren't taking
anyone and how about my identity as far
as hey i'm just gonna go back to my home
wherever in this village and just kind
of take up
life as a normal yeah farmer or whatever
i mean you could go and do that i think
eventually they track you down and not
and i think this was also a bit of a
misnomer that happened in the beginning
was people were talking a lot especially
in the news they were oh taliban's got a
list they're coming to houses they're
getting you know xyz they're targeting
so and so and when i i looked into it
they weren't really necessarily and of
course there
some peop there are exceptions but the
their overall goal wasn't necessarily to
target any of these soldiers their goal
was to take back government weapons so
any government vehicles any government
issued guns
they needed to take them back so the
process is when somebody surrenders they
get they hand over their weapon and they
get given a letter from the taliban so
the talibans give them a letter that
basically says they've surrendered this
is their number they're free to go
um so you know when talibans approach
some of these soldiers you know they
either have to show the letter and if
they don't have the letter then the
talibans will want to know where their
weapon is and and
and what they're doing kind of thing
so yeah it was
muddying
okay so you now you're in uzbekistan you
get there
by what august 20th you're in uzbekistan
yes around yeah august 20th so at this
time it's getting cr it's getting
crazier in afghanistan you got bite and
biden is now on august 20th makes his
promise
that all american citizens are going to
be brought home
august 23rd
the cia director william burns meets
with the leader of the taliban
um or one of one of the leaders of the
taliban
well co-founder of the taliban actually
to start talking about how we're gonna
withdraw
that starts to happen the withdrawal
starts happening august 26th
that's when this attack happens
kills 13
u.s military personnel 11 marines one
one navy corpsman one
american soldier about 70 odd
afghan 180 180 that went up 180
yeah
that happens on august 26th um
august 29th
there's a drone strike
that
is
allegedly targeting um some isis k or
some taliban or
and it ends up killing a usaid worker
worker
um
a guy named zamari ahmadi
kills him two other adults and seven
kids
um
august 30th
there's some rocket attacks uh but
august 32 when the last u.s planes leave
afghanistan
the taliban rolls into the airport
just rolls into the airport and declares
victory
and
so there it is now the taliban's in
control
at which point
is this when you go back in yeah so i
was working between uzbekistan and and
tajikistan and i would have gone back or
tried to go back a little earlier but
but
when i met with these diplomats um
you know one of them sort of said to me
and he
had said you know because he was sort of
involved in being
you know putting me in touch with the
middle man to leave afghanistan and he
sort of said you know i've been doing
this for 30 40 years and
been in many war zones sort of working
and he said i've never felt
more terrified when then i basically
handed you over to the taliban to get in
their car to leave and he said i just i
was so relieved
when you were okay and i out of respect
to him i didn't want to go back in
straight away so
but there was never a doubt in my mind
that i was going to go back in of course
i didn't tell that
to my parents or to anybody else but i
thought i i planned to come and do a job
i felt confident enough to go back
because despite the hype that that we
were sort of seeing in the media and
everybody trying to get out i did know
other other sort of british journalists
and things that had stayed that was
still in kabul and i felt confident
enough that i could go back and and and
be okay about it and
um
so we yeah we made that decision to go
back and i thought you know i'll let
this airport chaos die down and so we'll
go back in on the first and we'll drive
back from the north back from uzbekistan
border and we'll take that it's about a
12-hour drive across afghanistan back to
kabul because there really wasn't any
other way and yeah that's that's what we
did we
we came in we crossed that bridge again
um and you know i still and they were
honoring the the valid visas so my visa
was valid um
media visa and so i went back and and
you we kind of went to this little
passport hut and there was just a
taliban sitting in there and he didn't
ask a single question just had a
notebook wrote it down
stamped with the taliban stamp and we
were good to go so it was sort of that
easy to go back and i thought gosh
and then you're just driving south then
we're just driving so we'd hired a
driver um for friends of our friends
who'd come to pick us up and so there
was you know all of us jammed into this
little toyota corolla
driving you know from
that bridge down just through selang
pass down into
yeah it was about 12 hours are you and
you're getting the checkpoints
yeah so there was about 16 checkpoints
and what does that feel like
you know and still now they barely stop
you when they see a woman they see a
woman go go go go
they've been basically instructed at
least definitely at that point they're
instructed don't question a woman don't
um you know if there's a woman in the
car just let them go why is that they're
terrified of women they're they
they yeah they just they they think they
see it as a sign of respect don't
question a woman don't ask her who she
don't look at her don't
um question
really only once we got stopped
um i think at a checkpoint and they
asked us sort of a few questions looked
at the passports and
one of them pokes his head through the
window
it was again the it's like being a clown
show
and jake said to this guy how do you get
your hair so shiny because they've got
this black hair that's floating around
and the guy looks he goes head and
shoulders
the whole thing was like i was like i
don't know what movie i'm in right now
but this is crazy
um but yeah so they i barely got stopped
at a checkpoint and then suddenly we're
back in kabul and really at that point
the only fighting that was really still
happening was in pangaea and that was
sort of the last
holdout that the talibans hadn't taken
yet
so
and you ended up going up there right
yes and the reason you go well because
there was there was
there was anti-taliban forces that fled
there yes
and they they were flying the flag of
the northern alliance right up there and
it seemed like that could be sort of the
like the
yeah like the montana
or the or you know what i'm saying like
the wyoming of
hey hey they might have taken the rest
of america this is like a red dawn
scenario right these are the wolverines
up there thinking all right we're gonna
go up there do you know what i'm talking
about yes okay because i know echo does
because
you know he's very up to speed on on
those kind of movies but
that's what it was that's what it seemed
like up in pangaea was hey we've got
this is the last holdout we're like the
wolverines up there
we we're flying the old flag of the
northern alliance
and we've got experienced fighters
[Music]
you're hearing that story did you
looking at it think that they could hold
out so i was hearing a lot of
information people were going to do this
this this and this
and i've spent a lot of time in pangaea
previously and i knew that there was a
lot of great fighters great guy you know
people that that fought during the
soviet occupation and that was the only
place the talibans never controlled
during their reign in the 90s they never
got pangaea that was the one place so
they certainly had this this mentality
to hold but at the same time all the
young men that i knew that had lived
there had all fled to france all of them
and i'm thinking why have you fred
deflant why have you fled to france like
you should be here fighting for your
province like what is going on so a
little skeptical to be honest because i
was hearing especially from
contacts of mine in the us who were like
we're gonna send them weapons and get
this and i remember just sort of
thinking
i i don't i don't know if i'm buying
this right now
so we decided um yeah i was like i need
to get in and there was still this
debate going on has it fallen has it not
fallen because the talibans were
claiming in that sort of first week of
september to have taken it but then the
nrf as they known the national
resistance front was saying no no we're
still we're still in control and so
nobody could figure it out because
nobody could get in the talibans were
not letting anybody go into the province
and there's really terrible cell service
there it's just it's always been
terrible self-service there so
especially if you're in the mountains
you're not going to be able to report
back so
there was this really crazy debates
going on and
and again where the misinformation was
coming out of was this idea of um then
people started saying well pakistan has
got drones there and you know they're
supporting the talibans and i looked at
the video and then i was like that's a
video game
like they're using footy like news
outlets are using footage of a video
game seriously and also footage of like
hell us military in arizona and it's
being passed off as
the pakistan is in pangaea
and i just remember thinking what the it
was this complete disinformation circle
and when i really started to dig into it
i found that it was a lot of the
disinformation was coming from india so
basically pangaea had become this proxy
for the conflict between pakistan and
india and they were sending different
information a lot of which was
completely inaccurate
so
i said to my fixer
and we need to do whatever it takes to
get into pangaea because i need to know
has it fallen hasn't it fallen what is
going on there
and so he was able to make that
arrangement and we were sort of the
first journalists that were able to get
in and go through all eight districts
and that was about
that was once i want to say it was about
september 9 i think i did we went to
pangaea
um and did you drive up there yeah we
drove so it's it's not far from kabul
it's about an hour and a half
and then we we get there and it was very
heavily fortified by the taliban and and
we get in and immediately it was very
clear to me the taliban had complete
control of it um even
even yeah there was just so much
misinformation did you talk to any nrf
fighters yeah i did and most i was
watching them surrender from the
mountains and and they were coming down
and handing their guns over to the
talibans and the talibans were giving
them the ladder and off they were going
and they were leaving and
honestly and i got so much heat for this
but it you know you can only report what
you see in here
there really wasn't a fight it wasn't a
big fight a lot of that was exaggerated
there was not a single amount of damage
that i saw anywhere in that main street
not to say there wasn't fighting in the
mountains
but i i didn't i heard one rocket
launched that entire day that i was
there
the leadership had fled they'd already
left
um
and i just think that was just sort of
and i still hear it now about you know
people going around trying to get
weapons trying to you know
it's not there it doesn't exist the way
it existed
30 years ago
and again goes back to so many of them
that i knew they're not in the country
anymore
but
you know and it was crazy i got so much
heat for simply reporting
there really wasn't a fight here and the
the diaspora just came after me and
people you know i just i'd never
experienced that kind of backlash just
from reporting a story
um so i was i was kind of relieved when
you know some friends of mine from wall
street journal in new york times and
things they went in a couple weeks later
and reported the same thing so i was
like well okay i'm not crazy
um yeah that's
the the when you talk about the the
folks that you knew
that went to france like give us a
little bit of background on that well it
was just in that initial evacuation
period just a lot of the young fighters
that i knew that they france was france
was very close with with the pangaearis
and and um amacha massoud his wife lives
there and he spent a lot of time there
during his time and so they have a very
close relationship and the french is a
very aligned with the pangaea so they
were mostly able a lot of the men were
able to get
um i guess sivs to go to france in that
evacuation period and
a lot of them took it and off they went
and
um
so yeah i i don't doubt there was
certainly a fight there but i just think
it was really blown out of proportion in
terms of any ability to to take it it
was very clear the taliban had full
control of every single of those
districts
so you spend what how long were you up
there for a day yeah
you spent a day up there and now
at this point now the taliban is forming
their government
and
um
yeah
they now run the country they form their
government september 11th they kind of
formally announce that they're in
control and this is the new this is the
new regime yeah they reopened the the
ministry
um you know for the prevention advice
and propagation of virtue which is
uh something that existed in their first
reign where they would go around with
these morality police and and school
people and people get flogged if your
beard wasn't long enough or if a woman's
you know wasn't wearing the correct
burqa
so they were very very stringent about
that they haven't restarted the morality
police but at the beginning it was a
little bit terrifying and i went to the
opening of um the ministry and we sort
of just it was very bizarre that very
first month you could just walk up and
knock on a door anywhere and get in
they tightened down since then but it
was suddenly you just had all this
access to things and because the
talibans were not used to all this media
and people and it was very bizarre for
them so they would just sort of sure
come in what's your what's your opening
line when you walk up to the ministry of
prevention of vice and propagation of
virtue what do you say when you knock on
their door we just come i go with my
fixer my photographer and of course they
don't look at me um they
you know that was the other bizarre
thing too i the psychological effect of
being ignored and
um
invisible for a month straight is
actually to say it made me a little bit
crazy so but i would make a deliberate
at first for the first few weeks i was
being trying to be polite i would stand
back and just let them go up and you
know handle it and and do their passion
greetings with the talibans and make ask
the questions and i would just be in the
background they would interview with me
they didn't like it they would complain
and say why did you bring a woman you
know wish i should be interviewing with
a man but they would usually and my
fixer would say well she'll go she'll go
and write about it
she'll go and write about the fact that
you aren't going to interview her so
then they were very worried about
perception at that point um but so we
we'd go up and they were doing this you
know big opening for their you know all
the guys went in and i couldn't go in so
my photographer and fixer went in i was
allowed to go into the compound
and i'm some of the talibans bought me a
chair and i'm sitting under the tree
like
and they're all you know doing their the
haqqanis and everybody's in the building
next to me doing their their sermons and
then and then finally they said we need
to put her in a room she can't sit here
so
i get moved to a room and they're
bringing me tea and fruit and it was all
just very bizarre and then finally when
the celebrations had finished and
they're all doing picnics outside um the
director came to to interview me in the
in the little room and he would just
sort of sit there and um very softly
spoken and would answer my questions but
looking at the ground so i was yeah i
was very invisible um which at first i
took i said you know i'll be you know
i i went with the approach that they're
not used they've never seen a woman
before especially not a woman working
out with men
they if lucky they've seen their
mother's
daughter if they have one and their
sister they really have not seen a woman
before so i tried to be like well this
is very new to me are you wearing a
burqa or no no no i refused i wore
everything that i normally wore in
afghanistan previously just to her job
and sometimes i wore a mask depending
but i refuse to wear a book i refuse to
wear in a crib i refuse to wear anything
other than a hijab because that's all it
says in islam is cover the head and
that's it
so that's what i went with so i thought
you know this is a very big learning
experience for them too
and even when i would go to villages it
was so bizarre you could hear the
villages in the background is she a man
or a woman like they'd just never seen
it was just so new to them
and so at the beginning i was respectful
and then i i snapped i i i didn't i just
when you're ignored completely for that
long i just thought i'm not okay with
this anymore um and so i made a very big
point
of any time
we went to meet with the talibans that i
was with my photographer and fixer i
would walk up and i would just stare at
them
i'd say hi and i would stare at them and
they looked the other way and even an
interview when they would speak and they
would just look at my fixer and not to
me i would continue to stare at them and
95 of the time they broke 95 percent of
the time eventually they started to look
at me
and throughout the course of my months
there i found that by the end
most of them were actually looking at me
and i thought
i don't want to go and perpetuate this
idea of
it's okay just to ignore a woman even
though to a lot of them that is respect
they think it's respectful to not look
at me or ignore me and i thought if you
are going to run this country you need
to learn
what that is going to entail and that is
going to be that women are working in
the street
that's how it is foreign women will come
in and work
um so it's just an interesting social
experiment but
yeah staring at them
so there's like a line because you know
early early you said you know that when
the taliban would they wouldn't look at
you and you were like oh when the cars
they would just wave us through
checkpoints because it's a sign of
respect but then when you're actually
trying to communicate with them and
they're just not even looking at you
were there were they afraid
yeah it's just what they're taught
they're taught to never look at a woman
it's just it's indoctrination that it's
disrespectful to to look at it at a
woman that's not your your own wife or
your mother that's the way that they're
they're taught so
um
i understand that but
they're also going to have to learn
that's that's not always going to be the
way yeah and you said
hey it's not gonna this is the way it's
gonna have to be in the future but do
you think it'll be that way or do you
think i'll just not allow it i i i i saw
a big shift over that few months again i
tried to take the approach of
as much as this is new for me this is
new for them too like they've never been
in a media spotlight the way they are
now they've never had all this social
media and attention and
and
so they're navigating something new as
well and so
i think that
i think that i i hope that they've
learned i did see a change in in it over
that period just in
in their interaction
um
i know you actually i talked about that
drone drone strike earlier yeah and i
know that at one point you actually
twice i went and met with the family
at the house where it was hit
yeah
talk us through that yeah that was
devastating so
yeah on the edge of kabul very small you
know sort of impoverished area
um we went to see that family on that
first day that
basically that the pentagon had
acknowledged that okay it was a mistake
and it was heartbreaking it was
absolutely heartbreaking and one of the
you know it was three brothers that were
all sort of living there with all their
family and
waiting to get that call to go to the
airport to evacuate
and
one of them the men had lost all his
kids all his three kids were killed and
another one two of them
just it was
heartbreaking the car was all still
there
and
i just i can't imagine that the guy had
gone to work that day he was working for
an ngo and they sort of had a ritual
where the little kids would run up to
the car when it came in
and he would you know then they'd jump
in the car and they'd drive into the
into the house
and
so he came back in five o'clock that
afternoon and
that's when the drone hit and the kids
had all sort of ran out to get the car
and jumped in
and that's when they were hit with the
drone um
and it was just it was devastating you
know the mothers who just who could not
speak
and
i went back to follow up
with them um a couple of i guess it
would have been in november so
late november so recently and
i you know i said has as anybody because
there were reports that you've been
compensated the the us was going to give
them compensation and also
speed up their visas to come because
some of them did qualify for sivs and
had applied for them before the
evacuation so before any of this had
happened
and they said you know we haven't heard
a thing we have nobody's apologized
nobody's contacted us
and in in the u.s kind of saying oh
we're going to give these people com
pump compensation it endangered them
further because then people around
thought well these people have money now
and you know and and crime in
afghanistan as terrible as it is and so
suddenly these people were under an
extra layer of threat on top of it so
i don't know what sort of happened if
anything's transpired over the last
couple of weeks i tried to put them in
touch with a rescue organization that
was going to help them get out and speed
up and they said oh you know we're
supposedly in contact with some lawyers
in dc but
i don't know that anything ever came out
of that either or you know if they were
able to get out but it was really just
heartbreaking and in many levels and and
what's fascinating is that they weren't
bitter people they were not
they were not angry at the us they were
not um
you know they didn't want to try to get
revenge they want to come to the us you
know they still wanted to come and live
here and get out of afghanistan
but
yeah i just hope that that that case
isn't lost is there any
news or information about the sort of
intel thread that led to that drone
strike
i mean only from what i've read out of
reports was just it seemed like a
i guess a perfect storm of fire really
it just seemed that
and again i'm still trying to understand
it was like you were targeting a toyota
corolla well 70 of the cars in kabul are
toyota corollas
so
i just think it seemed like a perfect
storm from many different levels and i
think the us was in panic mode at that
point having had the airport attack a
couple of days earlier and was so
terrified that this guy who was pulling
water out of his car
was pulling explosives out of the car
and
yeah it all just seemed to come together
without
i guess the correct due diligence
i
i've done targets before hit targets
that were just
it was wrong and and that was a huge
lesson learned from me i hit a target
one time my first deployment to iraq and
and pulled the thread on the because i
got back thinking that was not right
like that that person the guy that we
got is not a bad guy he clearly was not
a bad guy and it came back and started
pulling the thread hey who who did this
who gave us this information and
eventually pulled the thread and it was
um like he had his wife had fired
the maid
or something like that it was something
like that
the maid was pissed
and so she went and started telling
americans that oh yeah this guy he's a
bad guy he's financing you know that
kind of thing
um
and so that was a huge lesson for me
because from then on
my my question would be who put this x
on this building because that's what we
would literally get would be a a map and
there'd be an x on the building a red x
just like a movie a red x on a building
and i would say who'd put that red x
there
i want to know who put that red x and i
would pull the thread and find out
exactly hey this is the information that
we've got this is what's corroborated
it's really really hard
and if you're not in that mode and
there's pressure
that's where these people make these um
quick calls
to to try and do something and
you know again i don't i'll i want to
pull the threat on that more and
hopefully i can try and as it becomes
declassified because i'm sure some of
it's classified where they're getting
information from all that stuff can be
classified but it'll be interesting to
pull the threat on that and see
why they pulled the trigger on on that
mission and the report came back saying
nobody was responsible nobody was held
accountable it was just a mistake that
that they couldn't sort of pin to one
person was the pentagon report on it i
thought how is that how is that possible
and how is nobody held accountable to
this at all
well you know even for me
when we hit that target and cap caught
this guy thank god we didn't shoot him
thank god he didn't resist he didn't
resist because he wasn't a bad guy so we
went we grabbed this guy but
the reason i wanted was so engaged with
that was because
i knew it was me
hey i'm the one that's kicking in the
door and we're you know well my team is
doing that so i need to take ownership
of what we're doing and
make sure that this is the right thing
to do in the right situation
because
yeah i mean so
if they're if you're allowed to sort of
push
responsibility onto 14 different people
that all had a hand in the intel
gathering which a bunch of people do
gather that intel but who's pulling the
trigger who's saying yes go and you need
to own that if you make that mistake and
explain why and then you can put some
procedures in place that
won't let it happen again
and also you have to question a little
bit
you have the inspector general of the
air force investigating the air force
like you know
would it be better to have an
independent person looking at this as
opposed to
having somebody investigate themselves i
don't know i i don't it's just sort of a
question that i've asked myself
and there's another thing that can
happen as well
and this was a term that i first heard
when i was in iraq my second deployment
good shot bad result meaning when you
lay out what happened what a individual
saw like if the person that pulled the
trigger what he saw what he understood
what he was thinking you lay all those
things out
and you say you know what
you that was a good shot i understand
why you took that shot i'm sorry that
this is what happened
but
we at least we at least investigate and
say okay how did this happen
how did this occur and how do we make
sure that first of all the person wasn't
being negligent the person's not trying
to hide anything because look when
you're in war
you're gonna shoot people and
occasionally you're gonna shoot someone
that didn't deserve to get shot
that happens and when that happens you
have to actually look at it and say okay
how did it happen how did you make that
decision why did you make that decision
what did you see you pull all that stuff
apart
and
with my guys
the couple times that something like
this happened it was hey i understand
why you took that shot and and
it was actually the right call and i'm
it's horrible that has a bad result but
i understand why you did it and it made
sense
you know that's a lot different than oh
wait a second you
didn't see anything that looked
suspicious or you
you know why did you shoot this well i
don't know no never got that answer and
never was in those situations so
for to your point
for to pull the threat on the whole
thing if someone said hey this is what
we saw this is the vehicle that we were
targeting this is the intel hit that we
got this is what our informant said this
is what our electronic surveillance said
they could actually paint a picture
where you say
you know in that pressure situation i
understand what you did i understand why
you took that shot and you took the risk
at taking that shot so you could save
americans and save an attack i
understand that
okay now we we at least learn something
but to just say
nothing
it doesn't make sense
it's not it's not the right move man
freaking horrible
um
you also
i mean you were like on the freaking
taliban tourist trip i mean you you went
to uh visit omar's like remote mosque
out there what was that
so we took this you know again taking
advantage of the fact suddenly we went
to i went to almost all the provinces
because this was something that i
couldn't ever do before by road
suddenly we could we could travel and
this was fascinating to me
so we took this epic kind of journey
from
kabul to kandahar and you know through
logar and then wardak and then through
um ghazni and actually was very bizarre
in ghazni after we started the filthiest
hotel that i think i've ever stayed in
my life
there was the sheets weren't like it was
it was gross and mind you this was still
september or it was very hot gotta give
us a bad yelp review for sure it was it
was i just didn't have hang asleep the
toilet didn't work like there was just
one shared squat toilet that didn't work
and the shower didn't work and it was
over flooding and i just i just could
not wait to leave that place but anyhow
what's so bizarre i like the fact that
you're jumping into random cars with
taliban elders but you don't get mad
until you got a freaking stuffed up
shower but you know it was so bizarre so
we're sitting there in this little like
place having dinner downstairs and again
it's very unusual for a woman to be out
at night now it's like oh you know
effort i'm going out so i'm having
dinner with yours my driver my fixer and
my photographer and
then a bunch of kandahari talibans come
into the restaurant and sort of sitting
there and
and
staring and doing their you know asking
a few questions and went about their
business but anyway i found out the next
day which was very strange the hotel
the and because i have to stay
separately to the men so the guys all
shared one room and then as a woman i
have to have my own room so i was on the
other side um and then these kandahari
talibans so bizarre they stayed they
were traveling through but they stayed
that night because they heard there were
foreigners there and literally like
stayed outside
my room that night to make sure nobody
came in which was just bizarre in a way
it kind of goes back to their pasture
and wally hospitality wanting to make
sure nothing happened to the foreigners
um
which
yeah we can we can talk about that
because that's that leads to so many
different things but that sort of shows
you this very
bizarre dichotomy of what is happening
in this country because on one hand
you're sort of seeing acts like that and
then on the other hand you see the
brutality and you see this insurgency
that's trying to be a government
so yeah very bizarre but
anyway we continued to go through to
kandahar which is the birthplace of the
talibans um on all the roads they bombed
up you know i'd ask them who bombed this
road oh we did well now you've got to
fix it right like now it's time because
yeah the roads are terrible so you know
we eventually got there
and then it's about two hours um from
kandahar city to go to this little tiny
it's in in sangiza which is where mulla
oma started the taliban in 1994.
so we drive there and and
get to this it's extremely primitive
place it's just mud huts it's it's dirt
roads it's
and somewhere i really think that the us
just never was because it was just it
was taliban territory forever so we get
there and just this one tiny square room
um
in the middle of
middle of nowhere
and go in and and the imam
and these village elders welcome us in
and it was actually strange again
because that was the first time
that and it was at omaha's mosque that
the the muellers were actually looking
at me and talking to me i thought this
is just strange because i'd come from
all these other places and here should
be the most conservative of all and yet
you're actually engaging and asking
asking me about my personal life
you know so i just thought this is
bizarre um but you know their their sort
of philosophy on it was that that mullah
omar gained traction and and gained
supporters because this came after the
there was a civil war going on so after
the russians were
kicked out of afghanistan
you know quickly things became another
war again which was the civil war in
afghanistan and mulla omar presented
this idea of there was going to be no
corruption and the crime was going to
stop and he would give
food and money and things to the poor
and and people gravitated to that and
you could see
just from sort of the simplicity of this
tiny little mosque that you know looked
like the carpets weren't replaced in 30
40 years
that that was really something i think
that he did live by was this um sort of
sense of humility and i think a lot of
afghans at that point when they were
starting to see
corruption among all these warlords they
gravitated to that and that's how he was
able to
to build a very strong following very
quickly
um you mentioned to me about
seeing people addicted to drugs there
what what's that culture like because
it's the mecca for opium yeah yeah
absolutely i think it's something more
than 90 percent of the world's heroin
and opium come from afghanistan
so
and the taliban is really proud that
that has been one of the number one ways
they were able to make money through the
insurgency was through the the selling
of of those drugs and
they
a lot in helmand we went up to helm and
to uh sang in and places like that where
they grow the poppies and it's funny
because i went
the taliban were putting on this big you
know display of we're getting rid of the
drugs it's haram we're going to kill the
crops and blah blah blah and um
and i was at the canon narcotics and
and and the guys you know they're
putting on this display but then it
became very evident to me
especially when i went there and the
talibans themselves are harvesting it
and i said well
so you tell me it's haram and then one
of them says to me it's only haram if we
sell it to afghans if we sell it over
the border it's not haram so basically
they said
we can sell it to other we can kill
other people in other places but we
don't want to kill um
we don't want to kill afghans so that
was sort of their philosophy i don't see
them ending that anytime soon they're
going to try to i think probably find
avenues to legalize it in the sense of
um
countries that perhaps are friendly to
them that need opium for for medicine
i think that's the approach that they
seem like they're going to want to take
is is to try to legalize it in some way
now they were using the jails to they
were called rounding up a lot of the
addicts from the streets and and there's
a lot of addicts in the streets and
rounding them up and putting them in
jail because they didn't have proper
rehab so that was sort of the approach
that the talibans have been taking
and kids too there was a lot of sadly a
lot of young kids
is the cult is there like a drug culture
of some kind or is it just something
that sort of seeps into hey this is what
we grow you start trying it you start
eating it or whatever you know there was
like one little boy that i talked to who
was 13 and he was addicted and he was in
this jail and i said well how did you
start taking this and he said several
years ago he'd have to go and buy it for
his dad so he'd go and buy
get the get the you know puppies and
heroine for his dad and then eventually
he just you know tried it once and and
and he became addicted so i think it
tends to to filter through families and
really impoverish families usually
um so yeah just
now
you eventually do get like uh detained
and kind of accused of being a spy right
what happened
so that was also in kandahar so
what happens is as a journalist so just
to go back a little bit so when you get
to the country as a journalist you have
to go to the the ministry of information
and culture which is sort of like the
ministry of foreign affairs and
they check your credentials and give you
a mujahid zabiola mujahid is the
spokesperson basically gives you a
signed letter that says you were
accredited journalist to be able to work
and and you flash that letter so when i
am going through a checkpoint or when
i'm going to try to do an interview i
flash my zabiola letter and they say
okay she's pressed she can come in or
whatever the situation is so and when
you go to a province you have to the
protocol is you're supposed to go and
inform the minister of information and
culture that you were there so that they
know that you can get through
checkpoints and you're not going to get
arrested so
in kandahar that's exactly what we did
we went to the ministry of information
and culture and did an interview with
him about blah blah blah and he said
okay
you can go anywhere you want goodbye
sort of thing so we're like okay well
we're going to spin boldac which is the
border of pakistan in kandahar that
sort of leads into uh into that tribal
area
so
into quetta so we
go down to spain boldack and there's
just people everywhere trying because
the border is mostly closed and there's
people everywhere and
instantly i just get mopped like
absolutely i'm talking just just
flooded by hundreds of of people that
just surround me and i'm
you know with my fixer i'm like don't
don't leave me because these people are
gonna mob me so i'm trying to intervene
just you just get mobbed it was it was
crazy and and
the talent is just because you're
western yeah yeah i guess they saw they
saw a camera and then they saw a female
and they thought okay jonas everybody
sort of they're curious they want to
tell their story but what was bizarre
joko is the talibans were flogging them
like whipping these guys to get them
away from me and i was like please stop
that like i don't want to be responsible
they just continued just to follow i was
like you're just getting whipped and i
was upset about it because i didn't want
people getting hurt
why why are you not leaving when this is
happening
it was bizarre and so what ended up
happening was it just it got to the
point where it was so much there were
just
just people everywhere and just what was
the closing in on me this town was like
what who what what kind of town was this
was like like our super bowl
town border town so it was just a border
crossing so it was a small bit just so
many people but they were just freaking
hyped to see just just it was the
craziest thing and i
i mean you have that a little bit but
this was a whole other level where i
just thought oh my goodness like what is
happening um i couldn't go anywhere and
i would try to grab people to interview
them into a store and i'd look out the
window and suddenly the store was just
surrounded
it was so crazy and
i said i just i didn't i and so the
talibans were coming along asking
questions what is happening and we tried
to call the driver and we had this funny
driver called shafiq and he
um
he always likes to eat and every time
he goes he tries to find eat and
suddenly shafiq's not in the place that
he we left him sophie had gone off to
get food at the
bar and the car wasn't there and and and
and the weed my fixer is calling shafiq
where are you he's not answering his
phone
and so the talibans come along in their
police vehicle and we're just trying to
crush your feet and i'm telling them
like we're leaving we're leaving um
we're just getting our driver we
couldn't contact the driver and so next
thing you know television's like all
right get in and i said i don't want to
get in your car i don't want to go to
the police station and they said nope
get in
and
so we get into the police
vehicle we go to the police station and
they put us in their detention room
and we're sitting there for a while and
i'm thinking this is going to get
resolved really quickly hours and hours
and then finally just more of them are
piling in and the top intel guy is
piling in and all these talibans are
piling in
and i'm showing them my credentials i'm
showing them the letter i'm showing them
the passport i'm showing them my press
card and they said oh this is fake
no it's not
they said yes it is and they're you know
con accusing us of basically spying and
i just i don't i don't know what else to
tell you i'm
a journalist i've showed you my
credentials i've showed you my passport
you have all my information
so i i don't know what to tell you so
we're sort of sitting there
more people are coming in hammering us i
can see my fixer starting to get white
and he's a very sort of cool calm
doesn't really things don't rattle him
too much but i can see he's starting to
to get worried and
doesn't know what to do
um and they're telling you know it's
about these pakistani spies that they
arrested a couple of nights earlier and
and
long story short eventually many hours
later they were able to get in contact
with the the zabiola's office who was
able to verify our information and and
then they were extremely apologetic and
they said well we'll take you to the
border and you can you know photograph
the pakistanis and at that point they
were fighting with the pakistanis
so um
yeah i guess
that was so we ended up going to the
border and getting you know some good
interviews and footage and they were
very very apologetic about the situation
but
that was just one of those those
situations where that that usually is
the case for journalists is that
especially working in the middle east or
in asia like afghanistan they will
accuse you of being spies and you have a
little recourse to argue and say well
i've showed you my credentials i'm not
but i don't know what i need to do to
convince you anymore you've got like uh
survivor's bias but
you just leaves make it through
everything it's crazy like there's so
many people that this your story always
seems to end up working out yeah it does
yeah touch on touch wood on that one um
what about the haqqani you you visited
coast kind of so host yeah so that was
um that's sort of where the haqqanis a
lot of them come from that and pacquia
and uh yes so that was interesting so i
have a good friend of mine who's from
host and so we went down there and you
know it was an interesting place because
it
you know again as the sort of the home
of the haqqanis but it was very
untouched a lot of the time by actual
conflict it was one of the few places
where you had roads that were decent and
that
um it was a very self-sufficient kind of
place but but yeah what struck me in
going in
is this big billboard of beau bergdahl
that's
just there as you enter
as you enter the city
and it's bo bergdahl in another muller
like a salute to beau bergdahl no it's
not it's him looking down and like he's
sort of got blood on his face and he's
looking like he's detained and miserable
and then there's this muller standing in
the picture next to him and it's a poem
in pashto that doesn't really make a lot
of sense but it's basically a tribute to
this muller and i'm still very unclear i
thought you were saying it was a tribute
tribute to bob
it's almost sort of like
a
it's a tribute to the muller but for
some reason they felt the need to put
the bow bergdahl there it's this new
new billboard and then i found out that
the host the governor of host is
actually one of the gitmo five so i
guess he put it up there to you know
celebrate himself in some way and
and he actually invited us to go and do
an interview which i didn't end up going
because
he didn't want i went and met with the
mayor but i didn't go and meet with him
because my he didn't want my friend the
friend that had the hosti friend who had
taken me to host he didn't want her to
go so i i felt sort of obliged to i mean
just just explain that taliban five
point in case anyone doesn't know about
that so i guess when when beau bergdahl
was traded
um he was what captured in 2009 he ran
off base i think something he deserted
his base in uh in in the neighboring
paxia which is next to host and he was
captured by the taliban and ultimately
the haqqanis took him and he was i guess
yeah under captivity for a long time and
then eventually under the obama
administration i think it was in 2015
they orchestrated a deal to release five
uh gitmo detainees
uh in exchange for for the one us
us soldier so
and now now that one of those guys is uh
what the mayor what is he he's the
governor the governor he's the governor
of host now yeah they're all in top
leadership positions
they're all running the show
and they're connie's themselves i mean
saraj is wanted by the us for five
million dollars is now the minister of
interior and his uncle khalil is the
minister of refugees
which um yeah i don't know i don't know
what that entails
it's crazy so how about the
let's talk a little bit about this so
you know you mentioned the haqqani you
got taliban akane and taliban are
very aligned right um
in fact they they kind of say there's no
difference between the two even though
there's well the haqqanis are actually a
designated terrorist organization but
the taliban isn't
but i'm saying in afghanistan they're
very close well now it's basically
entwined right i think before it was
there were slight sort of ideological
differences and in in many ways the
khanis were they were the leading they
were attacks yeah they were the hardcore
most of the suicide bombings were
orchestrated by them they were the ones
kidnapping who still have americans in
captivity
but um and i mean
very close with al qaeda you know the
founder of the haqqanis haqqani himself
yeah this was a guy that was you know
funded by the cia to fight the soviet
union reagan called him personally a
freedom fighter yes
yes
so when we talk about things for being
bizarre right now
they've been bizarre for a long time
they've been very bizarre for a long
time we paid
him millions of dollars
um
the the founder of the haqqani and
i think he's i mean it's a fascinating
guy you know i mean he was um
he's got two wives got seven sons i
think
three or four of his sons were killed in
combat yeah and he he's the really of
the one who brought a lot of the arabs
into the fold so until that point it was
very you know afghan pakistan
he started getting a lot of the arab
funding which brought in the bin ladens
and a lot of that kind of funding but um
but what what i found to be really
interesting in in really researching the
akanes is
they're very educated and they're they
get a lot of education a lot of their
their wives go to the middle east go to
saudi arabia and get
educations which is ironic given that so
many of the women under the taliban are
deprived of education so it's sort of
this dichotomy but but everyone i know
who's worked closely or knows that khan
is well will always say they're 20 steps
ahead of everyone else like they are the
brainchild really of the taliban so they
know
what is going on down to a t and siraj
does not get photo there is not a
photograph of suraj that you can
possibly find a grainy photograph the
fbi has but it's very old and very
unclear
he does not get photographed at all and
he did an event
once when i was there which was
um
celebrating suicide bombers at the
intercontinental hotel which of course
the haqqanis you know sent suicide
bombers to several years earlier the
whole thing is great so when did you go
to this thing was this on this i didn't
go in but this was in this was in late
october they had
they were giving land and compensation
money to families of suicide bombers
which we can get into because they are
very much continuing this suicide
bombing despite being a government
but they um
so he's doing this big event there but
in every photograph that was taken it's
him from the back or him from the side
or his face is blurred and i said to to
one of my sources there who was he works
for him who's a kabul intel taliban guy
and i said well you know what is up with
that
and he says suraj will walk around the
street every few days
and nobody knows who he is so he will
walk around the street to check you know
what's happening at the checkpoints
check what the talibans are doing
and nobody knows who he is and he's
going to keep it that way undercover
boss yeah
but there yeah there it the whole thing
is just crazy and then
you have so he's minister of interior
and then you have mula omar's son
muliyakub who's only about 29 30. he is
the
minister of defense and those two are
bat heads they don't like each other
they're coming from different schools of
thought so
it's just
it's a crazy world
and then outside of those two groups you
have isis k yes
yes so they you know they've had a
presence in afghanistan since about 2015
but essentially were pretty much
defeated around 20 i think the afghan
government in early 2019 basically said
that they were defeated and that was the
whole idea of the us's mission up until
i i guess trump authorized them to go
after the talibans but up until then it
was al qaeda and then isis
and
they've really made it a terrifying
resurgence there's almost daily attacks
happening across afghanistan as i was
there
and and they are like
even more hardcore than the haqqani
is that accurate
they've got a different ideology so
what makes the talibans and and the
khanis different to isis and to al-qaeda
is
they're very talibans are very much
focused on afghanistan they don't have
any grandiose desires they they say we
want to make sure that no foreigners
come into our country we want good
relations with everybody but we don't
want another foreigner to come into our
country they're like isolationists yes
they're very focused on afghanistan
whereas groups like isis and and al
qaeda have a much more global ideology
where they they want to see as the
fighter said they want to see their
interpretation spread throughout the
world and they're the ones that will
plant attacks in in other countries so
therefore are viewed as a as a national
security threat
whereas the taliban isn't and that's
really hard for the afghans to
it's always been hard for the afghans to
really wrap their head around because
the talibans were doing so many suicide
bombings and attacks and and to them
they're absolutely terrorists and they
couldn't it was hard for me to explain
to them why the us
was sort of leaving the talibans alone
and going after these much smaller
groups that were at that point not even
doing that many attacks
and that is is going back to well the
talibans is not a threat to the united
states necessarily in it in and of
itself
did you you went to the area where the
taliban blew up the ancient buddha yeah
beautiful province beautiful province
1500 years old those statues were
you know and that was that was crazy so
what and i i talked to the telemanns
about this about you know was that a
mistake and so
they say no no no that that wasn't a
mistake that was the decision then but
now we're going to protect everything
and so i went to a few other places with
ruins and the talibans are all
protecting it and i said were you going
to continue to protect these buddhas or
you know in mazanak and other places
yeah yeah yeah that's our orders for now
but what we have to remember is this
might be their orders for now but they
didn't blow up those buddhas until early
2001 so at that point the taliban had
already been in control what since 1996.
so
it was left alone
and then mullah omar did it as an
extortion because he wanted the
international community to give the
taliban's money and the international
community wouldn't so then he threatened
well i'm gonna blow up the buddhas
and still didn't get the money so he
made good on his promise so that's the
thing with the talibans right now they
might be okay where everything's okay
but you don't know what they're going to
do next month you don't know how the
orders will change
and so and you get there and it was
bizarre because the talibans were taking
selfies in front of these blown up
buddhas and i said well you do know
that that these you guys who blew these
up right it just you know incredibly
strange but birmingham is a beautiful
province it just it shows you
i think when we think of afghanistan we
just think of the war and the bloodshed
but it just is
is one of the most
remarkably
aesthetically beautiful places in the
world and then bamiyan is just a prime
example of that it was the first
national park in afghanistan
now there was a the drone strike that
killed the facilitator and planner and
you did a little
a little investigation on that as well
yeah so i went there a few times so that
was just outside dalalabad in nangenha
so nangan has always been the hub for
for isis k it's on the pakistan border
on the east and it's just that is where
you know tora bora is where bin laden
went and hid immediately
i also went out to the the moab side if
you remember when the us dropped that
massive mother of all bombs in beginning
of 2017. that's also in nangenha so um
so there's an area a couple of different
areas but but that particular area was a
district called sarkorod and that was
just outside of jalalabad and
it's one of those very eerie places and
you go there and you feel like their
skin and your your neck is standing up
because it just doesn't feel right and
so the house that was hit
was in the far corner it was actually a
really nice house compared to you know a
lot of the mud huts and things this was
a nice sort of brick home and we went
into the home
um and you could see where it was hit
and it was it was so precise it was just
like you know this
one section of the backyard in this
chair that had been blown up and nothing
else was touched
so i went and talked to to the neighbors
there and and one of the the guys who
who was there and as the drone strike
hit which was close to midnight he was
on i guess guard duty on a roof across
and yeah he sort of said that that there
was a strange guy that sort of hadn't
been living there that long but um
but would come and go and
yeah they hit that night and then sort
of immediately i guess a car came and
took the women out of the house and the
children
and then um the next day a bunch of
talibans came in and were were taking
things out taking flags taking he said
he didn't know what they were taking but
big boxes that were just weighing the
car down and then talibans went in there
after that and took out more things or i
guess from the house and then he said
that those talibans were found without
their heads hanging on a a tree the next
couple of days later with an isis
stamped letter next to it basically
saying anybody who removes these bodies
is going to to kind of be next and he
said eventually that
um if someone from another district came
to collect them but they were just
hanging there on that tree for for many
days because people were afraid of isis
and he said that every night sort of you
isis comes in they they come in and take
control but during the day it's very
much the taliban doing patrol the
taliban gets scared and disappear and
then
the yeah the isis fighters come in at
night and he even showed me his own
warning letter he got from the talibans
for doing a local news interview after
that drone strike and then he said that
the taliban saw the interview and and
were then accusing him of being the one
that gave the location to the foreigners
so it's complex and then the actual
isis-controlled center
where a lot of these people come from is
the next district over which is chapaga
so so we went into that one day which i
don't know it was a smartest decision
but i'm here today
you should play lottery
because you would win a lot
um
so
i know you left what the first first yes
first of december yes
so like a few days ago a week ago yes um
as you as you look back there's anything
else any other high points from there i
mean there's a bunch of stuff i'm sure
you you know um
on your website you've got a link to a
bunch of the articles yes yeah and i
have a sub stack that i also subscribe
to that and i usually put all
all the articles into that and also a
little bit of extra kind of so how do
they get to the sub stack so it's just
uh you can get it straight from my
website or it's just yeah it's and your
website is what holly okay
h-o-l-l-i-e-m-c-k-a-y
dot-com there you go and then you can
get to the sub-stack yeah go into some
more detail there but as you look at
what's going on um
what's
what's going on now this is a disaster i
mean
i i know one thing that you'd mentioned
to me is like
and it's sort of
the the
i guess the the like the ground or the
most granular sort of
point zero
for the disaster
is like what happened to the military
working dogs that got left behind
and you know that was such a big story
if everybody remembers there's about 130
dogs and you see these pictures of them
at the airport and so i wanted to to
follow up on that and find out what what
happened to those dogs because the dod
was very quickly to come out and say
they weren't
us military dogs but they were
contractor dogs so
the long story short is that you know
different uh contracting companies had
given
those dogs to a carnival small animal
rescue which is run by a woman named
charlotte and she was tasked with
getting them out but when she got to the
airport was basically told you know you
can't get all these dogs on the plane
and
you can only take out what you can carry
so there was a lot of controversy oh my
gosh these dogs are being abandoned but
you know she's someone who really does
amazing work in in rescuing these
animals and caring for them so i wanted
to follow up and find out what happened
to them and
i talked to her and she said they
recovered about 70
um
most of them or not a half probably had
been killed by the talibans and then you
had so a lot of the spaniels which are
very friendly dogs had run up to the
talibans and the talibans just not they
don't have dogs as pets when they had
the rule in the 90s dogs were outlawed
they considered unclean by the talibans
you can have cats but not dogs
so a lot of them were shot and then they
sort of saw that these dogs had gotten
so much attention and thought well this
is a bit of a bargaining chip so they
kept a lot of the german shepherds
because they thought that a lot of the
german shepherds must be guard dogs even
though a lot of them were not trained as
guard dogs but you see
especially at the airport and other
places the taliban's walking around
these dogs that they have no idea what
they're doing with like these dogs like
they don't look like you know so so some
of them survived some of them were left
to run around the airport compound and
some of them got out so yeah it was a
sad situation and and we can debate for
days you know obviously humans have to
get priority over dogs but i think we
all can agree we we love our animals
yeah well what about that what about
like the hum from a humanitarian
perspective of what's going on there now
it's an absolute disaster and that is
that is the heartbreaking thing is the
to give you some context when i got
there it was 70 afghans to one us dollar
it was a hun it hit a hundred by the
time i left so that just shows you how
quickly that devalued their their
afghani devalued their currency
people can't afford bread people can't
afford
just basic things there there is no
middle class in afghanistan anymore it's
people are selling their belongings on
the street
um
you know crime has gone through the roof
again it dropped initially because i
think people were in fear that they were
going to get their hand chopped off and
when it became prevalent that wasn't
going to happen at least not right now
the crime went back up and it's
you go to these public hospitals
and
i mean they were just there the amount
of malnourished babies that are just
dying on mass and the mothers are on the
floor breastfeeding and
it was something i'd really just never
seen to that degree and it broke my
heart because of the amount of money
that that we as americans and the amount
of treasure and the amount of people and
the amount of
you know effort that had been put into
this and and this was the result and
it's only going to get worse during the
winter and and and and the us and other
countries are going to have to make this
very uncomfortable decision
of
do we unfreeze this money this 9.5
billion that was frozen when the taliban
took over and
the world bank and and international
monetary fund also froze
do we unfreeze that and enable
this government to
to support a country of 38 million
because there is no money coming in
there's absolutely no money you cannot
get money out of the banks
um
yeah it was it was very challenging to
work in because of that environment
but we're going to have to make this
decision of do we work with this
government so that these innocent afghan
people who have already gone through so
much
can survive and have some kind of
dignity in their lives
or are we going to just i guess turn
away and say no no these people are
human rights violators we're not going
to to talk to them and to isolate them
and
and i always look back on history and i
hope that we don't make the same mistake
because there was no more isolated
government than the taliban during their
first reign in the 90s through to 2001.
they were blackballed by everybody and
they had no money the one person who
came in and gave the money and not very
much 1.5 million i think it was was
osama bin laden he's the one who came in
and gave them money and so naturally
they were going to protect him naturally
when the u.s said hand him over mula
alma said no
he's the only one who came in and gave
us money so it's a very complex decision
and there's going to be a lot of people
that feel very strongly in many ways
but it's an uncomfortable decision that
needs to be made
on a diplomatic level of how we're going
to deal with this because i think
the afghan people have been through
enough and and they don't deserve any
they don't deserve to suffer the
ramifications of this any more than they
already have
and
that that's that's sort of the
uncomfortable choice there isn't many
options
do you as when you got back to america
um i guess it's been a couple days ago
but even even as you were you know
overseas and you were online and you
were looking at
the way that the stories were being
presented and the way that the events
were being presented
with now
the you know the way the media and
social media and emotional media all
works now what was your
you know what was the delta between what
you were seeing and what the world was
being fed there was quite a dichotomy so
if i was just to look at twitter and to
look at what was happening i would think
there was mass slaughter on the street i
would think that that the talibans were
going out and pulling people from their
homes and
and and certainly there are isolated
cases of that happening
but that was very much the exception not
the norm and that was not accurately
reflected i think
you know as strange as it is the
talibans were trying to
show this image of
they want to be recognized
is it safe to say that the taliban is
trying to rebrand yes absolutely and and
i think you know there's a lot of this i
hear a lot of well they haven't changed
since the 2000 and you know or their
first reigns in the 90s and i don't
think that's accurate they have changed
they've changed a lot in many different
respects but um but yeah a lot of the
information i was seeing about these
just you know mass
slaughters and you know i think there
was one thing where
and a lot of people had asked me about
it there was a rumor going around about
a girl that had been beheaded by the
taliban and when i looked into it and i
asked my fixer look into it it turned
out that she had been killed in july so
before the talibans came in but it was
an internal family conflict it had
nothing to do with you know and yet this
was being presented as this just
happened last week and and she's being
beheaded and i saw like kim kardashian
or someone was then retweeting it and
putting it on
a story and then a million more people
are asking me and i thought this is how
this cycle perpetuates but if i was to
to sum up the situation it was certainly
terrible things were happening
but
it wasn't what was being painted you
know as i said i i could work freely and
and unharmed um and you know i was only
wearing a hijab so a lot of the
information just was was wrong and
there was something i even saw you know
there was a picture that was going
around where it was a woman in a burka
and she had a chain around her ankle and
was being led by a husband and people
were saying you know this is afghanistan
now under the taliban i looked at you
know a quick reverse image search and
you see oh no that was 2003 iraq and
somebody photoshopped a chain to this
woman's ankle so
there was so much of that and um
and i think there really were few
journalists that were in there i didn't
i didn't meet too many other americans i
met a couple of americans that came in
and then left again but generally there
was just a few european journalists that
came in and so a lot of the work was
being done from from outside the country
and i think it just shows you the
importance of being on the grounds and a
lot of news organizations don't want to
invest in that anymore
but afghanistan really showed me the
importance of of having the ground
perspective because it's it's so
different to what you see just sort of
an aggregating or even talking to people
and i think
you know a lot of interviewers were
talking to the diaspora people that had
fled but their perspective was no longer
in afghanistan so
yeah there's a lot of disinformation
um yeah and it'll be
no one knows right we don't know what
the taliban's gonna do um
you know they were
pretty brutal in their last
you know time in power from
1996 um
up until 2001 up until
up until the northern alliance and
america went in there and i mean they
had some
some some bad things happen right um
starvation and
and
just bad some bad stuff happened i mean
horrible it's uh you know definitely
human rights violations and all that
stuff absolutely has happened and
and you know there was obviously there
were some reports of
terrible things happening again and
it's hard to know
but to your point
unless you have people on the ground
you it's very it makes it even more
difficult to actually know what's
happening and make decisions on what
you're going to do when you're basing it
on photoshopped images
yeah absolutely um
you mentioned osama bin laden
what was
talk to us a little bit about osama bin
laden oh osama bin laden's presence in
the psyche of the afghan people now
what did you observe from that
perspective yeah so i i really think you
know his legacy is still very strong in
afghanistan and
even places that i went to you know in
again the jalalabad the the information
and culture minister there has told me
straight don't do any stories on a song
so i was like oh you wait you wait now
i'm going
um so but you see that legacy sort of
carry through and they're all in power
because of him and again it goes back to
he's the one who sort of came in and
gave them money when no one else would
and so in return for that they gave him
gave him safe harbor and it's under that
code of pashtun wally which is
really the highest moral code that the
the pashtuns have
in protecting guests and and it's the
same code that they use to protect
somebody like me who's a is a guest in
their country so it's it's a very
complex sort of thing but but when you
talk to regular afghans or or students
or or people that you know when they're
young
20 something they they don't know who he
is and it's it's just interesting
because you sort of look at
this war and you
that was continuing to go on and and and
yet you sort of have the people that are
caught in the crossfire who just sort of
have no idea of what what happened and
what the background is and and why this
is all
kind of still going on so
it's interesting and al qaeda still you
know certainly exists in afghanistan too
um my understanding from the talibans is
that they've been told that they are not
allowed to do any take any military
actions that they have to you know
they're allowed to be in the country but
they have to
to stop you know not plan anything or do
anything otherwise they'll be in trouble
but i think a lot of the times too
a lot of those al-qaeda members have
just been basically folded in into the
talibans and a part of the
intelligence units or a part of that
whole operation
yeah it was definitely some of your
articles mention the fact that you know
some 20 year old afghan didn't really
know who osama bin laden was yeah
so sometimes when
i get into discussions with people about
the divisiveness in america i'll
reference the fact that i work with a
bunch of different companies at my
consulting company and
most people that you talk to
they're not thinking about what's
happening on twitter right now they're
not thinking about this they're thinking
about what they're doing they're
thinking about their job they're
thinking about their company they're
thinking about moving you know how
they're going to grow how they're going
to go to new markets that's what they're
thinking about that's what they're doing
that's what their life is
is is it similar i mean
i guess this is a rhetorical question
but did you find the same thing in
afghanistan most people are like okay
well the taliban's in charge of the
northern alliance in charge i want to
you know continue to get my job done and
raise my family and move kind of forward
like kind of leave me alone type thing
you have two camps you have the people
whose entire day is is fixated on trying
to get out um trying to get out of
afghanistan you're trying to get out so
there's really two camps and you know
each even now just every day all day
my messages my linkedin everything is
just flooded how do i get it how do i
get out so you have that camp and then
you have another camp of people who are
just basically
um i know that i can't go anywhere and
this is the new reality so how do i
survive and how do i feed my family and
and that's really what it comes down to
it comes down to survival especially now
with the
the crisis being what it is there and
the challenges of of just day-to-day
life
what are people
when somebody messages you you get 10
messages
about i want to get out i want to get
out i want to get out why do they want
to get out what are they what's and it's
a mixed thing you have you have people
that are certainly have legitimate
reasons to get out um a lot of the
commandos that i met with that are being
terrified because the commanders are
really leading the charge in a lot of
the fights and and they're very
concerned about retaliation um but then
you have a lot of people who who and
again what i found a lot of people who
were maybe drivers or worked for
different companies who are desperate
and terrified to get out but when i talk
to them i say well where's the threat
nobody's been threatened or they're
passing around a whatsapp letter that
everybody's been
given that's fake or so
in a way that the fear is contagious and
again that's where i'm saying the fear
doesn't always match the reality
and what i found it was that people
thought well someone's so scared and my
neighbor's scared and everybody's scared
so i'm gonna have to be scared too and
i'm gonna have to leave
so
that yeah it was it was contagious and
and that's what i found that a lot of
the
the worries were were self-inflicted as
opposed to an actual
real threat that was there
there's got to be like a massive level
though of like suppression right right i
mean if you're a person that was sort of
open-minded and moving in this direction
yeah and now like it's over yeah it's
over yeah and and and you don't get and
especially for women too you know that's
deeply challenging girls are still not
able to go to to public schools i think
private schools are still open but
secondary schools have been closed for
girls now for months and the talibans
keep saying it's because we've got to
make sure that they have transport
that's separate to the men and i said
well great we'll get you some buses oh
and then there's another excuse so
i'm not sure what's happening with that
but you know women that were definitely
used to going to work and to other
places and now they're at home and you
know that's heartbreaking women you know
i met with many women who
you know were doing
um you know in the national sort of
taekwondo teams or in the national
tennis team yeah there's a big article
about their soccer team too yeah you
know and now that then they're not
allowed to to um to do their you know
to not even practice let alone go into
any tournaments even i met with the top
mma guy there as well he's you know
great fighter he's i think two fights
away from ufc and he's like we can't
fight anymore and he said they tried to
do a fight the talibans told them that
they have to wear like full clothing
which he said you know we obviously
can't do that and the taliban came to
their first fight and broke it up and
turned into a big mess but you know he's
concerned because you know he can't get
out but and he's trying but you know
he's someone who used to go to each
match with you know the police your
police you know afghan police flag and
it was very
pro the former security forces and so
you know it's tough for the guys too
even even though they can do well you
know a little bit more than the women
but music is completely
kind of outlawed and and arts and all
those sorts of things yeah you're not
allowed to paint any people don't know
how to paint any living things or film
any living things or photograph any
living things yeah well they haven't
been too strict about that but yeah
instruments have been outlawed yeah
except for like some drum yeah well they
they have this their music is this
nasheed music it just drive me crazy so
they would get into the car and they'd
put in you know insist and um if we're
driving somewhere remote and
damn talibans would get in the car and
they'd put in their nasheeds and it was
just this it's islamic music without
instruments it's all vocals and then
there's bomb blasts and bullets and just
like and they turn it up and i was like
it's like their motivation it's their
battlefield music and it's like this is
crazy and that's what they play all
night and the talibans actually moved
next door to the house that i was living
in so i would deliberately go and get my
two-pack and maybe again
i just blast it
completely
yeah and i was like you know what it's
time to go holiday
so here's here's what i find this is
what's this is what's so hard to
really contemplate as a as a human being
right
what percentage of people
are
are are
don't want it to be this way right what
percentage of people don't want it to be
this way
and
would give anything to go back to
whatever to 2019
and be moving in a certain direction
have the females ready to go to school
and be able to play your guitar and be
able to do mma what percentage of the
population
feels that way
versus what percentage of the population
wants to go back to the old taliban ways
and strict sharia law
i'm not asking you you can make an
estimation but it's very difficult
and then
okay if you're that
if you're 90 is on board for sharia law
and that's what we're doing and hey the
10 that aren't on board with it
you best get out of here because this is
what we're doing
or is it
90 of the population wants to just go
back to again 2019 move in that
direction move towards a more open
society
and if that's the case and it's just a
strict small percentage of people that
maintain power and control
via force and brutality
well then then then then what are we
supposed to do
so i think there's really again when we
see with the media what we're seeing is
always generally coverage that's coming
out of kabul or coming out of a city and
i tried to really make an effort to to
to go to as many rural areas and
provinces because the perspective there
is completely different
so i'd say if you're going to estimate
in somewhere like kabul you know 80 of
people
want
that previous life because they were
able to you know there was bars there
was music that you know could go to
clubs you could go to you know get
alcohol you could do all of these things
because you had that foreign footprint
there
um but you go to the villages and
you know that are already very
conservative where the women don't
necessarily you know go to school past
the age of 13 and that are very much
relegated to the home and they don't
leave and that's just customary because
that's that's the way that their life is
their lives are actually going to get
better and i say that because
they don't have to face the daily
bombings anymore they don't have to
deal with the ramifications of war but
their actual lives
aren't gonna change because they were
never really privy to all those sort of
new western inspired if you will
freedoms so you can make the argument
that you know for them they now have a
more peaceful life but in the cities
that's where you really see
women and people
losing a lot of those freedoms and and
suffering but but what i think is also
interesting that came out of this was
the number on of talibans that were
embedded into the military into the
government into every possible avenue in
every city
and suddenly when the talibans were able
to take power these people came out
people i knew for years and years and
years who were working with journalists
fixers said to me oh yeah i've been
taliban for 20 years
and now they're out you know and so
and friends of mine you know i had you
know even with my fixer good friend of
his he was saying that someone he's
known since he was very young when the
taliban took power suddenly he finds out
his taliban like it's just
these people kept secrets for so long
and i think that's also why the talibans
were able to come to power so quickly
they infiltrated every possible
you know government entity that they
could
um
what do they do what's the taliban doing
with their with the with the military
equipment that they took over so um i
you know it was interesting so i did a
tour of the airport just before i left
and and you still see a lot of the
damaged aircraft the us blew up a lot of
the aircraft before it left but you see
a lot they still have all those russian
russian helicopters that are still there
and and they have a lot of engineers
they brought back a lot of the
technicians from the previous government
trained by the us that are now they're
able to to help you know repair whatever
they can
um and they still do have very limited
air power but i know that's something
they're trying to build because the air
force is something that that they want
that they didn't have before
um and it was funny because i was i was
sitting outside you know one one
afternoon and
and you see there was there was a big
blast a big bomb and and the smokes in
the air and it was just it was down at
the military hospital very close and
next thing you know you're hearing
choppers in the air and i said i haven't
heard this for ages you know what's
going on and they were flying a
blackhawk and two of the the russian
mh17s and they had apparently dropped a
suicide bomber onto the hospital because
isis was attacking it
again they're still using suicide
bombers for situations like that but
yeah craziness so it was it was an
ongoing it was an ongoing you know thing
but but so they certainly have the
capacity if they need it but they're
saying oh we're just going to use it for
important and urgent circumstances so
yeah the whole thing is is backwards but
yeah i actually went to a suicide
bombing school that i found which was in
a kindergarten on the edge of kabul
where they train the suicide bombers um
you know and you have these men just
begging begging to be chosen
just pick me pick me it's like the
highest
honor that they could possibly take and
and you know if despite being a
government now there's no plans to to
get rid of the suicide bombing schools
um
how about what are you seeing for
lessons as you look at it now you're
looking back on it you've been gone for
a week now what are you looking at what
what kind of big picture strategic
lessons are you seeing my biggest thing
that to to drive home is you know we can
talk all day about
military
strategies and and the taliban military
strategies but at the end of the day
and i i feel like i'm a broken record
saying this but corruption corruption
corruption corruption the last
government backed by the us
there was so much corruption on every
possible level to the point where
if you wanted to go and get an interview
at the u.s embassy just an interview if
you were a university graduate who
wanted to to get a job at the embassy
because that was that was a cool thing
to do
you had to pay a middle person about
five thousand dollars just to get an
interview let alone if you were to get a
job and then you'd pay them a whole
bunch more and that was in every
government institution
money you know and and this is what i
would get angry about because i would
tell a lot of these afghans i said
that's my money as a u.s taxpayer
you stole our money or not you
personally but your previous government
you stole our money and you took that
and you lined your pockets kabul could
be dubai by now two trillion dollars and
this is what has come from it
and that is because
the corruption on every level was just
so rampant and so disgusting and even
even when you know a lot of these awards
and people were fleeing the country when
the talibs were taking over there was
just there was chunks of gold that they
were keeping you know hidden underground
just wads of cash that
just in unfathomable numbers and
there was not a thing that you could do
to get through daily life without paying
a bribe
you know to get through a checkpoint
you're paying a bribe to get whatever
you needed like life for afghans was
difficult because of this
institutionalized corruption that i
think the us looked at and said well
this is too systemic for us to do
anything about we just have to leave it
but really to me that was the root of
the problem so people looked at that
afghans looked at that and were like why
am i starving here when
this local governor is is
rolling around and with all this money
and a rolls royce and all these fancy
things
and i can't you know i have to pay every
day every time just to get to my job
and that's what the the taliban really
capitalized on that they capitalized on
well we are not going to be corrupt you
know that's against islam we are going
to
um you know support everybody treat
everybody the same and so people that
didn't even ideologically want to be
you know with the talibans they were
driven to that and i i've seen that in
many countries you want to fight against
the government that you feel is is
stealing from you
and
it just got to the point where it was it
was so bad you had you had judges in
provinces or lawyers like just falsely
accusing people of something and and
taking them to court so they could get
brad money so it just and it was just it
was on every possible level even even at
the hospitals you had medical staff
stealing the surprise supplies so they
could go and sell them at a local
pharmacy or because they owned their own
pharmacy and that was going to pay them
better money than the government salary
so
you know it's if you're going to go into
a country or give country any sort of
form of foreign aid
i i hope that the us or and the con
other countries can learn that lesson of
if you don't stop that right in the
beginning if you don't hold people
accountable and there was there was
never accountability to any of the
corruption or stolen money
this is the result you're gonna get and
i saw that in iraq too with you know
people joining isis because they wanted
to fight back against the government who
they felt was stealing from and were
corrupt and was suppressing them and it
wasn't about we want to be part of isis
because we agree with isis it was no we
we want to fight this government because
they're not here for us
that's the
when you pull the string on vietnam the
south vietnamese government was just
completely corrupt and a lot of the
issues that they had were due to the
exact same type of corruption the whole
the whole
um system operated on through corruption
and scratching each other's backs and
you know getting money here and putting
in your own pockets and
you know that was just the way it worked
and that was a huge part of the issues
that they had and why
it's the exact same thing it's literally
the exact same thing um
seeing it again
i know that um
you know you've been you've been gone so
you're over there for august september
october november december that's like a
uh deployment yeah a deployment into a
into a war zone where everything's
falling apart what is that
that's i mean are you coming back this
time how's it how's it how's the
transition back to
reality back to norm
normal american life yeah it was
incredibly difficult i think for me to
leave this time um
i felt tremendously guilty about leaving
because i knew that that i can
as an australian and an american i can
get
you know i'm able to get a flight out to
abu dhabi and and able to leave freely
when it's something obviously a lot of
afghans want and i felt tremendously
guilty because
again you know i never think my life is
any more valuable than theirs um i just
happen to be lucky enough to be born in
in different
geographical coordinates that have given
me a different different passports and
and um
and a very different life and you know
the afghans are some of the most
truly
beautiful people they're just
so hospitable
very kind um
i i have a great love for the afghans i
always say that i've been to many places
in the world but i i've never quite sort
of fallen in love with the place the way
i've fallen in love with afghanistan
over the years and it's just it's very
special people and i felt tremendously
guilty
um just i guess you know walking away
from them and i knew that it was time to
leave and i knew that
um
you know some of the decisions that i
felt that i was making um as a
journalist were
i i was taking risks that i knew were
were
i shouldn't be taking um
and i think when you get to that point
when you sort of maybe don't care so
much about the outcome it's time to take
a break and that's sort of a point that
i think that i'd gotten to you know
especially with going into some of the
isis areas and
and even my photographer was hesitating
and i
was okay oh i'm fine i and i didn't have
the same
i think normal reactions you should have
to those situations just you know the
natural sense of fear or worry and and
so anyway so i knew it was definitely
time to take a break with that but i
think
yeah i felt very guilty especially those
first few days i
i was just you know wanting to turn
around and immediately go back
but um my first thing i saw i couldn't
go for a run and i'm a big runner and i
couldn't go for a run for you know five
months and so the first thing i did when
i got to new york was go for a run
and
i'm running and i look and i see a sign
for a beauty salon on the sidewalk and i
said
oh they've reopened the beauty salons
that was my first instinct and i thought
hang on a minute
you know you're in new york city now so
you're not in kabul so
um yeah it's actually
yeah it's it's a it's a strange
transition and as i said when i'm
driving down i'm looking at the roads
thinking how great they are you know how
great is this road why did nobody bomb
this road and then just remembering
um remembering where i am so it's um
yeah it's a little bit of a transition
but and so how long are you going to
stay home for
oh i don't i don't have a home right now
i don't how long are you going to sleep
in places where there's beds
i do need to get a home actually that is
the objective for for early 20 early
2022. scary um i am going to get a home
and so i have a good base so i i think
i need in america yes so i can
probably probably virginia i think maybe
i kind of like that area and then what's
on the horizon for
you know what are you gonna do for work
wise are you gonna are you gonna you
know you wrote only cry for the living
which is an incredible book
that really gives such a clear picture
of
everything that went went on um with the
isis battlefield in the levant
what are your plans on this stuff so i
have so jake and my photographer and i
have a photo book we're working on and
he's got some really just beautiful
pictures of afghanistan throughout this
transition and then i i'm going to
knuckle down and get the writing for
that done
um just sort of it's a way to present i
guess afghanistan to people in a very
visual way
um you know just sort of showing people
what what it's like to to be there
through the fall and then in that period
after and and who the afghans are who
the talibans are who are all these
different players
so that's the writing project i'm
working on and then just yeah continuing
to do journalism and little bits and
pieces of different things here and
there so
how much writing is going to take to get
that book done not a huge amount it's
not going to be super word intensive
because of the pictures so probably
i have so much material already it's
really just a matter of sitting down and
sorting through what i think is going to
be the most compelling to go with the
pictures that we've already selected so
kind of like a humans of new york but
kind of more like humans of afghanistan
yeah a little bit and then sort of go
into some of the
some of the decisions and some of the
major things that were done and
and said and explain things in in a in a
way that i hope people can resonate with
really
yeah that's that'll be uh that'll be
awesome i mean i didn't think of that
connection until just now like the
humans of new york which is a
fascinating book and
and obviously your your uh jake take
just just unleashing picture after
picture over there i'm sure he's got
incredible photographs and then the
context that you can put around those
and the history that you can put around
them and the the knowledge that you have
that's um that'd be awesome yeah so
just uh yeah continuing with the writing
and then i will return to afghanistan
probably in the spring is my is my plan
at the talibans will have me back if
they're not too mad it's
a lot of stuff i've written some of them
have been pretty mad do they contact you
um sometimes they contact my fixer and
and threaten and i had i had an issue
with one taliban's for a long time that
just drove me nuts i was a little bit
worried about him actually what did you
say about it he was just very angry
about everything and angry and just just
an angry person
um but eventually i just i just said i
don't care i don't care i don't care
come and get me i don't care
well they can't get you here but maybe
no no kabul i i say i thought should i
leave and they thought no i said come
and get me tell him to come and get me
come to the house if he's worried come
to the house
because he was like where do you live
come to that but anyway he backed off
and went away but most of them um
i think you know i think they have a
media team that tries to read through
three three read through reports but
they're desperate for recognition so
they want they want attention but
they're
increasingly becoming very um cracking
down a lot which in the beginning they
were very open and very free and it was
quite easy to get the interviews but
toward the end it became very difficult
to to get any approval
well
i don't know you kind of remind me of
alex honold you know who that is alex
honold is the rock climber that climbed
el cap without any ropes and
he's they do like tests on him and
there's no
he has let he registers less fear than a
normal human and i think you're kind of
like that i think you register less fear
than normal human so el cap is 3 000
feet in yosemite straight up granite and
he climbed it with no ropes there's a
uh incredible movie about it
um called free solo
but i when he did that
i remember just thinking man i hope that
guy never climbs without ropes again and
of course he does it all the time
because that's the way he is so when you
got back i was kind of like okay cool i
hope you never go over there again
but i guess that's like asking on alex
hornell not to do what he loves yeah i
guess
yeah and i'm very grateful for the fact
that i
i just i feel very compelled and i i
really do love what i do when i don't at
this point in my life i can't imagine
not doing it i don't know what i don't
know what i would do is it just
like curiosity it's curiosity it's
it's just
it's being this rough draft of history
that i just think is just a fascinating
experience to have and and it's
something i really thought about a lot
you know you're sitting with all these
talibans and they're bragging about
killing americans and they're bragging
about shooting down um you know american
helicopters and and they're you know and
i
i really had to reflect on it a little
bit because
i thought i'm in this situation you know
what is my job here and and
and i think what journalists can do is
it's it's not to
hear this stuff about being a voice and
giving people platforms no that's not
how i see my job i see my job as being
able to communicate
the other to the people and i say that
because
we have to understand the way that they
think and we want to it's very easy to
paint things as black and white as as
this is the good guy this is the bad guy
but you have to understand
why they do what they do where this
comes from what their impetus is and
that's the way that i sort of see a lot
of journalism is not to go in and
interrogate or to stick it to them or to
you just have to go in and have a
conversation and sometimes that's i find
it to be really difficult because
you know he's somebody that's that's you
know bragging about killing americans or
or
and yet you still have to go in there
and have tea and talk to them and and
it's
it's a balance of of sort of this
compartmentalization with
running from a place of humanity but i i
see that as
that communication as being something
that that really journalists can do
the best because you know we aren't
government employees so we don't have to
we can speak to anyone we want and and i
think it's an important job to be able
to
to understand you know where they're
coming from and what that objective is
and you know one of them said something
interesting i'd love to get
what your response would be because i
didn't have a i just didn't have a
response
but he he looked at me and he said
you know if
how would you feel if i went to
australia and i started recruiting
australians to kill other australians
wouldn't you want to fight me back
i thought about it for a really long
time and i didn't i didn't have
i didn't have a great response because
as i said earlier afghans were not the
ones who who drove those planes into
into
new york that was they were saudi osama
was found in pakistan so we can sort of
debate about what role afghans really
even had in those attacks
and so in putting myself in his shoes
you know i didn't have a great response
for
how do you respond to that yeah well
that's the important thing about what
you said earlier and this is something
that we don't do a great job of and by
we i mean america and west the west in
general is trying to understand what
other people are thinking right and if
you don't understand what other people
are thinking
as a i mean this is what sun tzu said
2500 years ago in the art of war you
have to understand
what your opponent what your enemy is
thinking if you don't understand what
they're thinking
your chances of winning go down
dramatically so anytime you try and
impose your thoughts
[Music]
on the enemy or you assume that you
understand what they're thinking you're
making them you're making a huge mistake
you're making a huge strategic mistake
when you let that happen so when you
talk about what you do as a journalist
of saying okay let me set my emotions
aside and let me listen and let me ask
earnest questions about what they're
thinking and why they're feeling that
way and then you actually listen to what
they have to say that is something that
people have people should do every
single day first of all as a leader in
any organization as a parent and in a
family as a child in a family in a you
know spouse in a relationship
in a governmental situation
that's what we should do that's what you
need to learn how to do is try and
understand what other people's
perspectives are and you can only
perspectives are if you ask ernest
questions and you actually listen to
what they have to say and you'll
probably figure out that what you
thought they thought
is not accurate
so
there's a you know there's a whole a
whole road to go down with that but
that's something that we don't do very
well and you know i think journalism
nowadays
is a whole it's just a while it's not
what it used to be certainly i think
you're about as close to an old school
journalist
i mean you're i mean i know there's
others that are like you but you are in
the model of the old school journalist
that's out there to gather information
and kind of report what's going on and
like you said you know you're reporting
about
what the the um the new northern
alliance
was
how well they fought and you're like oh
they there wasn't much of a fight and
people are mad at you
super mad at you because
you told what you saw and now maybe if
you would have said there was no fight
and i didn't see you know there was no
fight at all
and i don't remember your quotes from
that article but you know it's like hey
i didn't see any fighting i
saw
you know the taliban moving very
dominantly through the area so you're
literally saying what you saw
you're leaving room for you even said
today you said hey there might have been
more fighting in the mountains that i
didn't see but you're saying from what i
saw on these heavily populated areas
there wasn't any resistance
or there was very limited resistance i
saw one rocket that's not a lot of
resistance
so um i i think that that
people listening asking earnest
questions is something that the world
has forgot how to do part of it is i
would say the driving factor and that is
our own egos to think well i know
it's like the worst thing to say the
worst thing to say and even in a worse
thing to think is i know i know what
you're thinking i know what they're
thinking i know what the enemy is doing
you don't you don't know and the minute
you think you know is when you start
making mistakes
it's when you start assuming that you
understand things and you don't
so
i think what you're doing is extremely
important
i'll still go with the alex honold i i
actually don't want you to go out back
to afghanistan uh but i know you're
going to um be safe
and
and we'll keep track on you
anything echo you got any questions
yeah what exactly is the fixer so sorry
a fixer is something that journalists or
ngos even but primarily journalists when
we go into foreign countries we hire um
sort of a local person sometimes they're
a former journalist sometimes they're
just a connected person and they you
know help often will be a translator um
and they will help uh sort of help us
facilitate interviews and and make calls
and and just kind of yeah work with us
it's almost sort of like you know i
ended up calling my fixing a weed a
producer so essentially he's kind of
like producing for us you know he's
doing a lot of the background and and it
was really funny when we went back this
time because for the last 20 years all
the afghans and and the fixers have been
speaking dury which is a sort of an
afghan dialect of persian but now it's
all pashto everything's written in
pasture because that's that's what the
the um talibans use so a lot of the
people that were you know fixing for 20
years are suddenly like well i can't
speak the language
that's needed so it was a big big
transit a lot of the fixes have all left
the country so it was this very much uh
we had to find new people to work with
so it was a all a big learning curve so
it's kind of like the las vegas vip host
yeah
[Applause]
you know he's got that different
background yeah he was in the nightclub
industry for a while so for him it's
like oh that's the vip host yeah
i can get you in that back room hold on
let me talk to fred over here we'll be
taking care of yeah so my poor fixer is
you know having to talk to the the dash
and all these people on my behalf
um holly we can find you
at hollymck.com
you're on instagram
holly s and it's h-o-l-l-i-e-s
mckay and mckay is just m-c-k-a-y
you're on twitter you're on facebook it
was crazy to watch you on instagram when
you were over there um and see you
putting like instagram live yeah up and
you're reading like oh you're reading
people's stories like i look at echo
story oh it's like he's in his kitchen
he's making a freaking sandwich oh i'm
i'm posting that i just got done working
out and you're like i'm in a hotel in
mount maurice rio sharif and that's
we're surrounded by taliban
wait a second this is uh interesting so
yeah people holly mckay dot sub
stack i think it's the url
okay so the sub stack that's where you
put your information up awesome holly
anything else
thank you for having me and for yeah
letting me talk
talk some more about afghanistan i think
it's very easy for these things to fall
off the news once
once you know the evacuation happened
and it fell off the sort of the radar
very quickly but i think it's something
that's
very important to americans and
important to you know to
my generation who really grew up you
know with after 9 11 and and so many
people that i knew that went to fight
there and i think it's important that
that we keep afghanistan you know
somewhere in our minds
well
you're certainly helping us to do that
and thank you for coming back to talk to
us and
thank you for making it back to talk to
us and thanks for letting us know
for all you do to go out there and let
us know what's actually happening and
reporting it so that the world knows
what's really happening
it's uh definitely an eerie window into
the heart of darkness and it's a big
risk for you to go in there
physically
mentally
spiritually but you're doing meaningful
work
and it does have a big impact on the
world so thanks for doing it thank you
appreciate it thank you thanks holly
and with that
holly mckay has left the building
awesome that she could stop by
and
kind of share some of that stuff with us
lots of lots of lots of craziness in the
world
and sometimes seems like all that
craziness that's going on in the world
what are you gonna do about it
how can you help it
look
i don't know what you're gonna do
for
some
young
girl that's
getting no education in afghanistan
right now i'm not sure what you can do
about that i'm not sure
but i do know this you got a little
control over your world what's going on
in your world
try and make your world a little bit
better that's my recommendation man
that's crazy how she mentioned the
corruption you know like how much of a
felt like i mean of course no one's
gonna be like yeah i'm totally down for
corruption no one's gonna think that for
the most part so but you don't really
understand
how important that is to be like legit
and squared away in that way and i
really had no idea
what she was going to say when i asked
her that question because even
you know reading through articles and
stuff you know i thought maybe she'd
have some strategic
uh
thing about the way we treated the trial
you know just whatever kind of the more
more uh common
complaints that you'll hear about how
afghanistan was handled and
yeah that was uh definitely very
interesting and insightful
aspect to bring up how
devastating corruption can be
because then then it's kind of like
nothing works the way it's supposed to
work exactly right yeah nothing works
the way it's supposed to work
when people
are corrupt think about everything the
way things are supposed to be
they're not that way yeah she said
something super quick too she said super
quick but i was like oh that kind of put
add the corruption into this this point
where she said some of the isis fighters
joined isis not because they
support the ideology it's just because
their government is so corrupt and it's
like bro
like the government has so much power
over an individual anyway so if it's
like they're corrupt and they're just
tired of that corruptness and they're
like you know what i'm going to join
this group who sure their stuff is kind
of crazy but
at least i can fight back and have some
power against this this government that
i'm powerless against that's corrupt you
know we we it's two things going on we
take it for granted in america
that things aren't corrupt
and we take it for granted in america
do you get my double meaning on this
what i'm saying is we walk around like
oh you know well this is american things
aren't corrupt here right
but we take that for granted and there's
things that go on inside the government
that are absolutely corrupt absolutely
freaking corrupt and the more that stuff
grows and also the more exposure it gets
because of
social media and because the way people
can share information and the way you
can
google information
it's just a different world and i think
that
the amount of information that's
available is going to start to become a
light
on
a lot of the corruption that's in the
u.s government yeah in the in now and
it's going to get even more so in the
future yes it's yeah like
when you get exposed for being like a
whatever some corrupt person like in a
in a position of power there it seems
like there's an element of shame that
goes along with it when you get caught
then again i'm no expert in afghanistan
so i don't know but it seems like it's
just so except more accepted in certain
places you know
yeah well like look at what just
happened with the cuomo guy from cnn
yeah
why did they get that well because he
had texts going back and forth that
wouldn't have happened
20 years ago maybe
20 were we texting 20 years ago
not too much the first time i ever
texted
was
we were in vegas
with task unit bruiser and
leif and seth
were texting
and they started texting me and i'm like
what are you doing just call me or
whatever because you're dumb right you
don't know what's happening
i'm like just freaking call me and
they're like we'll send you a text when
we get to wherever and i'm like
just call me why are you gonna text me
and then sure enough i'm sitting in some
bar somewhere and it's super loud and
get the text
and then just responding yeah it's like
yeah they remember the teen what do you
call t9 word you know the one it's not
not like a phone it's like actual
keyboard i gotta i gotta say i had a
blackberry
hell yeah when i was the admiral's aide
i got issued a black bear yeah that was
the best so then i had the blackberry
and once you have a blackberry it was
hard to do anything else because they
were freaking a super squared away
little rig
even my i got the first iphone
the very first iphone that came out
stoner went and got in line
and got us both iphones and three days
later you had like a three-day return
policy i took it back out i got my i got
my blackberry back
the blackberry was a squared away little
rig
and then now it gets crushed yeah now it
gets crushed by a
well it gets crushed by the iphone for
sure kind of everything because they
thought they knew they thought they had
a lock yeah they were arrogant yeah you
got to be blackberry was arrogant
isn't it funny how like even when you
say i texted like texting is so new that
we the language didn't even catch up we
just assumed that okay text is now a
verb so now we gotta accommodate you
know so because before then text is a
noun now it's a noun and a verb
so now you need past tense present tense
future you know
all these additional free things
hey i'm just saying english major you
gotta relate to this kind of stuff so
you're like oh yeah he texted me it's
like is texted a word well i guess it is
now what's the past tense for text text
just text
he texted me texted in the past right it
hasn't just said x t and then an e d
yeah texted yeah but see how that's like
a question kind of texting yeah we're
not sure it sounds weird text did
doesn't sound quite right yeah it's a
weird word to say yeah
so we got to be careful that
yeah we do
very careful so there's corruption out
there yeah um
lots of craziness in the world like i
said try and make your world
you know as squared away as you can yeah
how do we do that well
we have to stay capable i'll tell you
that stay capable stay healthy how about
that
you should just go with
the first thing on the top of your head
that you've utilized say like hey i was
tired the other day and i went and tried
the new freaking pre-workout and it was
savage and i ended up jacking big steel
yeah
well okay i will but it's not that story
because when i tried it when i
took some pre-workout i tried it a long
time ago when i took some pre-workout
hey i wasn't tired i just did it for the
power pre-workout okay
for the mind body connection experience
while working out okay didn't let me
down full on and it's kind of and it's
different you can feel the difference
like when you don't take it because i
don't take it all the time yeah so that
was my experience recently that was day
before yesterday is there a moment where
you say oh feeling this certain mode
right now gonna jump into i'm gonna
gonna get that little extra hitter right
now yes and what is it what is it
feeling uh what do you mean the feeling
that compels that baby yes yes um
it's pretty random it's not when i'm
tired though tired because it doesn't
have enough caffeine for me to be like
oh i'm tired i need to take this for the
tiredness two scoops that's yeah
whatever almost 200 milligrams of
caffeine come on bro what are you a
crackhead i'm not ready for the two
scoops yet
dude jp
at five o'clock in the morning yeah he
dry scooped
the new pre-workout
chased it with sour apple sniper
dry scooped another one and chased it
again yeah
that's a little bit beyond beyond my uh
uh capabilities
either way
yes pre-workout i did that i would say
the the more significant experience is
with the energy drinks
that's the one that's the one that gets
you yeah and very very
often like i drink them a lot
how often you drink them
i would say pretty much every day oh
okay just wanted what's your favorite
flavor mango by far 100
by far do you have anything else on
standby yeah kind of the rest of them
okay the citrus i don't really drink as
much
okay
but either way this is what you do
midday okay so i wake up i don't really
eat breakfast anymore me neither yeah so
before lunch i'll have one of those
that's good that's the good one buy one
of those you mean uh one of these energy
drinks discipline girl yes energy drink
healthy and gracie reached out to you on
me utilizing the term energy drinking
yeah did he send a cease and desist no
no he liked it okay yep props to him yes
he says
so yeah energy drinks that are healthy
no sugar sweetened with monk fruit good
for you healthier you're better off
after you drink them legitimately good
for you yep you pay no back-end health
price
with these energy drinks so yes one a
day is good here's another front-end uh
investment you can make
into your life into your world is get
joint warfare get super krill
so that way
you can proactively fight
the mayhem that's you're causing to your
own joints it's true you know how like
um you
take things for granted
joints are that and
as far as back to my experience i have
been taking my joints for granted
luckily i haven't like
had any kind of terrible learning
experience to remind me of that i just
every once in a while like it's i get
hit with it like for how old i am i feel
like i don't really have many joint
problems yeah and you gotta you know
what you gotta do too
you gotta continue to do you gotta
continue to do the work yeah man you
gotta you don't surrender any positions
yeah don't surrender any positions like
your workout positions like for me
overhead squat yeah overhead squat like
i hurt my arm real bad remember when
dean lisch
and i could not lock out my arm i could
not do an overhead squat couldn't do it
zero
and then finally it started healing and
it took months and months and months by
the time it was healed
my body had kind of forgot how to do an
overhead squat yeah
and
so the first time i tried to do an
overhead squat again my body forgot how
to do it
and it felt terrible and i couldn't use
any weight like barely any weight i was
using the bar
and part of that little ego in the back
of my mind the little complacency in the
back of my mind was like you know what
overhead squat's not that big of a deal
you should you know you don't really
need to do overhead squat uh yeah you
know and then i said to myself no if you
surrender that movement
if you don't do that movement you're
it's gonna go away forever yeah
so i'm very cognizant of that that's why
another thing like going deep on squats
the minute you're like well you know i
don't need to go that deep i'm going to
go heavy so i'm going to go less deep no
actually don't do that yeah correct you
want to do that occasionally okay i get
it we're
we're doing muscle confusion
right
all right but
don't you gotta keep those
keep those movements alive man keep it
alive and nothing but that's what
reminded me of that deep squats so like
okay so deep squats if you let's say
because some people don't have what the
ankle like a mobility or
for that but if you have ankle mobility
and then you don't do them for a while
then try to do them you'll feel like oh
wait i got to get my ankle like mobility
kind of back you know and here's the
thing when you say you lose it forever
it's in it's not like
you stop doing it and then it's gone
gone you it's you stop doing it then
when you start doing it it's like you
get it back but not all of it you paid
like a little tax yeah as time goes on
and the longer you wait the month longer
it might take to get back the bigger the
tax does same with uh muscle ups when i
could hurt my arm couldn't do muscle ups
couldn't do them you know
by the time i started doing muscle ups
again i could do one yeah like it was
and it was not fun yeah and so then i
was like okay well today i'm gonna do
three in my whole workout i'm gonna do
three muscle ups you know what i mean
you're doing the rings yeah ring muscle
ups so
it's one of those things that's what you
know what this is this is a little
a little tool to you put in your brain
to think when you have the moment where
you're saying you know what i'm not
gonna do this particular exercise today
just remember you're surrendering that
movement and i'm telling you please
don't do it so there you go don't
surrender surrender any movements don't
take it for granted either yeah take the
joint worst fear take the krill oil
that'll help physically keep your joints
in the game
that's on top of you keeping it in there
smoke you're gonna need let's face it
you're gonna need to rebuild if you're
doing overhead squats you're gonna need
to rebuild yes sir so you're gonna need
some milk some extra additional protein
that just so happens it tastes like
dessert banana cream pie if we're if
we're into it that's the new one banana
cream bomber yeah who thought of that
name you
maybe repeat
it's good too the design is good i was
also on origin usa the website and they
got whoever designed that that website
pete i'm just assuming
but well pete definitely designed the
the banana bomber thing yeah you know
he's super into the you know that's good
he's good man he likes it good design
yeah
he's making a black bottle right banana
on it
he puts
it no no no he sends me options yeah
what do you think of this what do you
think of this i'm like bro
right banana
so there you go yeah you like you bring
it back down like when you know because
oh yeah let's face it dude if pete was
running like had full crease yeah the
freaking banan the milk would come in
like a giant banana shaped bottle oh
yeah yeah like he'd get too creative but
then yeah then you're like the dichotomy
or whatever bringing it back down to
where it needs to be perfect
a little bit perfect it's all perfect in
my opinion so origin usa
yeah american-made stuff oh wait but
what about for the drinks you can get
the drinks at wawa by the way
you can also get
everything at the vitamin shop
so check those out
and then you were saying origin usa you
were saying
jiu jitsu you're talking about
genes genes
[Music]
everything at origin
is made in america straight up even the
materials are made in america it's an
american uh
economic
thing
[Laughter]
this is the uh uh what do you call it
recording right now
because it is a full-on american thing
yes it is correct it's not american
thing
so okay so uh bringing back certain
elements of this of the industry
to the point where it's almost it's kind
of bringing back and industry bringing
back all elements of the industry yeah
that's what we're doing freaking all in
one straight up um yeah you can get geez
which you should definitely get some
geese which by the way the geese are not
this isn't your this isn't your
father's ghee this isn't your mother's
key this is a new deal those keys are so
freaking nice yeah
get yourself one of those geese
also
just kind of fyi
we're making some stuff for hunting yeah
we're making a hunting it's not just
some stuff we're making a hunting line
yeah like a bunch of things yeah so when
you roll out
in hunting season you can do it wearing
american made gear
we'll keep you posted on that yeah
what else
oh you said the boots jeans there's some
wallets and cool accessories on there
and and i went accessories
you make it sound like that but like
look at the belt you won't be like
accessories you'll be like oh that i'm
getting that belt sure i'm getting that
wallet while it's kind of a minimalist
wallet though so if you're not into
minimalist wallets then you know maybe
there's a i think there's a maximus
wallet too not maximus but there's a
maximum
more
robust robust there you go all right
thank you with the vocab coming in hot
just trying to help
nonetheless a lot of good stuff on there
all made in america um and good quality
stuff so it's like from top to bottom
that's kind of the go-to when you think
about it so yeah origin usa.com also
did i say jacofuel.com i didn't
tacklefuel.com if you want that if you
want that uh
the supplement side of the house
all good
um yeah but yeah jacqueline store as
well that's where you can get discipline
equals freedom stuff shirts apparel
shirts hats hoodies
hoodies are back in
it's winter
it's kind of colder here and then
there's the short locker which
brief description short locker what do
you got it is a creative um
let's just okay but on the basic level
it's one a new shirt every month okay
but the designs are a little bit
different a little bit more
there are more layers to the designs you
know they're funner
i guess remember when jaco podcast there
was a whole thing about light layers yes
there is still a whole thing there's
nothing there let's think about layers
it's almost like it's just the
underground it's part of it yep just
layers so there's layers in the t-shirts
yep there's more to it than just a
straightforward design if you listen you
know if you listen if you listen you
know if you're in the game you know
what's up exactly if you're not you'll
be like oh yeah but if you could do yeah
so that's the whole thing about the
layers as far as layers go look if
you're not in the game you look at the
design you'll be like oh man that's cool
yeah and i get a cool one every month
cool but if you listen and you know you
know the other layers in it so now you
get the cool design
on the front end but then you get the
you know the meaning the dish
[Music]
back and so all good check that out it's
on
jacquelinestore.com hey subscribe to the
podcast uh also subscribe to jocko
unraveling rolling out some christmas
cheer with my point dc talking about all
kinds of lovely subjects
um grounded podcast we got the warrior
kid podcast
also you can join the underground
speaking of underground
docker underground.com we got a a little
something that we had to set up just in
case
tyrannical forces take over
we gotta have a place to go we got a
place to go it's called jocko
underground jocklinground.com if you
want to help us in there if you want to
help us be ready for any contingencies
that might unfold you can subscribe
it's eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month we got an additional little
podcast on there we answer your
questions and whatnot
if you can't afford it it's cool we
still want you in the game go to
assistance at underground jocko
underground dot com assistance at
jackonground.com there you go it's true
also we have a youtube channel
the video version of this podcast
some excerpts on there and some also
some additional
content
as it were you're gonna have to check it
out to see what it is but yeah every
once in a while we'll put some
additional stuff on there that turns out
to be interesting you wanna see what
jocko uh can't live
without
get that kind of video sometimes there
you go um psychological warfare mp3
tracks to keep you on the path we got
flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer selling stuff to hang on
your wall
we got books
only cry for the living mentioned it
today it's holly mckay's first book we
covered on podcast number 271 you can
get that from jackopublishing.com
jockopublishing.com
this is actually a book that
i published
why because
it's a freaking epic story from somebody
that spent time on the battlefield
when isis was being
fought and pushed back and she
interviewed people from isis which is
crazy
so if you want to check that out you can
go to jacopublishing.com
also
final spin it's a story it's a novel
it's a poem it's a manuscript it's
a freaking wild emotional ride
don't read it when you're in front of
people because you might be crying don't
read it when you got to be quiet because
you might be laughing
final spin
i wrote it leadership strategy and
tactics field manual the code the
evaluation the protocols desperately
freedom field manual warrior kid
one two three and four
that's the christmas gift
that's the christmas gift you're
wondering oh where to get this little
kid
yeah that's the gift get them to get
them all books
all books work way of the war your kid
one two three and four there is no
better gift you can get for a kid
than those books
if you got a little kid getting mikey in
the dragons
little mikey in the dragons
let him learn to overcome fear
about face by colonel david hackworth i
wrote the forward on the new version
and then extreme ownership and the
dichotomy of leadership who i wrote with
my brother leif babin speaking of life
we have a leadership consultancy if you
need help inside your organization from
a leadership perspective which if you
have any issues inside your organization
whatever problems you have their
leadership problems
leadership is the solution
go to ashlandfront.com for that if you
want to come to one of our line of live
events you can check it out there
we also have the online training academy
extremeownership.com
it's a online leadership training
academy
you can bring your team in there you can
get everyone aligned you can
get your whole company engaged in that
or you can just do it yourself
but you don't become a good leader
overnight and you don't you're not just
born a good leader just like you're not
born a good guitar player you're not i
don't care who you are you gotta pick up
and practice and learn
that's what the academy is for pick up
practice learn
for leadership go to extreme
ownership.com you wanna ask me a
question i'm there you can literally
just sit there and talk to me
three times a week two or three times a
week i'm there answering questions
live
so check that out extremeownership.com
if you want to help service members
active and retired
their families gold star families check
out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
incredible charity organization if you
want to donate to that you want to get
involved she is helping so many veterans
go to america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want any more of my looming
lectures or you need more of echo's
random retorts you can find us
on the interwebs on twitter on the gram
on facebook echoes at the charles i'm at
jacqueline holly is
on instagram on twitter
she's holly
s mckay
also holly mckay.com that's where you
can find her sub stack as well where
people it's a new
uh method
of putting information out there the
subset yeah a lot of journalists are
using it
it's kind of like a
patreon
but it's not being
controlled and they're allowing free
speech which apparently patreon was not
sub stack sub stack
finally
thanks to holly
you can hear uh what she does
the risk she takes to inform and educate
the world so thank you holly for doing
that
people
people who do not know history are
doomed to repeat it and someone has to
uncover history i liked what she said
about history history rough draft the
rough draft of history
so someone's got to go out and grab that
information
people like holly that go and do that
thank you holly for your hard work and
bravery to make that
happen any people in uniform out there
thank you for doing your best to
confront and stop evil in the world and
keep us all safe and that includes our
police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for keeping us safe right here
at home and everyone else out there
there is evil in the world and there is
good
and we have to be on guard and we have
to be
vigilant
[Music]
vigilant against evil vigilant against
corruption
these
thoughts and ideas can creep from person
to person and from mind to mind like a
disease
so stay vigilant stay prepared tell the
truth
look out for each other
and and try and keep your part of the
world
try and make your part of the world
as good as you can
and help other people do the same
and until next time this zekko
and jocko